all right and we are live
the last word lord cognito anybody's
fresh on that friday morning
u.s time fire gotta be gonna be clear
now we got a special guest man somebody
really cool but uh e first of all
what's going on with you man how you
been uh i've been good
uh mixing up different couple different
games i finished miles morales in a
single stream so literally straight nine
hour stream
if you haven't played that one you get a
ps5 ever coming your way please
please play that game for one the 2018
spider-man is stellar
i played that a while ago recently just
finished the dlc
and then and then so i while i was doing
the dlc i turned the
performance ray tracing on for the 2018.
that's already gorgeous and then you go
play
miles and you're like oh damn fine but
no miles is such a
like great tight experience like i
just i didn't mainline a store i did a
little exploring but i mean i could have
gone and got more collectibles i just
didn't
but it was like you know if you do 10 12
hours get some collectibles and i got a
decent amount of power-ups and level up
some things
dude that's such a good game and the
music too i'm just like
my head naturally like half my stream
had to be my head just doing this
yeah i thought it was on just when i
turned it on he's at the
in the train station just i was like oh
yeah that's that new york right there
yeah i'm here i'm in
me out of the way we got a we got a
guest in the house so we gotta do uh
the only way we know how to do this
let's see if we can turn him the color
of his uh
mike arm over there so bring him in
welcome to the last word episode 133
is in the air and the community
continues to be unhappy
what's new well tonight we are joined by
another brit who is ready to pull up his
seat at the campfire
this man's love of gaming started at
home with his dad
and a dream cast but from goldeneye to
halo
if a quality shooter exists he will be
there to pew-pew with the best of them
and i do mean the best of them he's
competed in call of duty pro scene and
took part in many tournaments and
battles over the years
but as with many of our guests when
destiny sinks its teeth in it is a hard
time letting go
and we tend to forget about most other
games so
let's officially welcome a content
creator for the electrify esports
his own youtube channel one who enjoys
the destiny community drama with popcorn
in hand
host of the crimson cast a family man
and a father of five living the dream of
chef by day
and gamer by night mr cloud plays
how are you doing sir that was
impressive
that was your best one i was
damn breathing halfway through that was
brilliant
i blacked out what happened
how you doing man how are you doing i
know we were trying to make this happen
for a bit and we got it to work so
yeah definitely yeah i'm going all right
i'm going all right i think at the
minute
it's just just trying to grind through
probably the hardest part for for
destiny at the moment so
tired is is probably the best way to
explain my life right now
i'm very real look long overdue
obviously
we've all been talking trying to get
this thing done you can make it happen
man so much to talk about man we got to
dive in man
so as as a gamer i'm seeing i'm hearing
about elite
skill and these shooters with cod and
all this stuff so like
how did that passion really start for
you like to really with the fps seat
i mean i think it kind of started off
way back goldeneye was was my go-to when
i was younger man me
my me and my dad hammered that game
hammered it
and but i kind of took a break from
gaming during like a lot of my teenage
years
a lot of my teenage years um and it
didn't come until the problem was about
in 1819
i started picking up gaming again um
fell into call of duty because as
somebody who doesn't really game too
much is the first game you pick up
um and just absolutely fell in love with
it matt was some absolutely awesome guys
in the scene and
we just decided to start hitting
tournaments and just going forward
which one which which which car first
which one model affair one model
for two so i started off on modern
warfare 2.
nice really started hammering into that
one um and but it wasn't until advanced
warfare
where i started to really show um it was
the speed of the game man being able to
bounce around
like some next level suited beast
was just it was so much fun so that that
that fast-paced gameplay definitely
pushed me forward so mobility is like
your thing so i'm sure destiny actually
puts up your alley for like
the high skill ceiling for mobility is
what usually sets a lot of people apart
yeah that's why i'm not good at pvp man
i'm a runner gunner
[Laughter]
destiny pvp annihilates me because i
can't take it slow
at all oh you got to be in the mix you
got to be up for that
of course my questions have to start
with food because this man is over here
so i gotta know how you got into it
what's like
what are you i know you said you uh you
told us but it's like let us know kind
of
how you got into being a chef what's the
background in food
and just yeah i was like i'm gonna have
a couple on this one because food's my
jam so yeah we'll be good
i'll be here for a little 100 100 i
think so i got into it originally just
as
a part-time job while i was in college
um i was actually studying public
services to join the police force back
then
um and i literally just did it as just a
bit of extra money
um met my misses a few years later down
the line wasn't really looking at taking
it forward too much
um a lot of things in life happen a lot
children happen
it kind of goes into a different
direction and this is
work to rear end off and started getting
into pub work
um and i just kind of went around with
that i picked up a lot of nvqs and
qualifications along the way and stuff
like that but yeah
it's kind of strange because like now
it's just we kind of run a business
of a british pub by the daytime and then
i come upstairs to my setup in the
evening and
running that absolutely awesome kitchen
team but it is
it's just insane i think that primarily
being able to to give people that kind
of
that that want for good food is
something that's that's really hones in
being able to give someone a decent meal
christmas time especially for us is just
is amazing just because like you can
either make a break somebody's christmas
do you know what i mean
if i pull up to the pub like what what's
the what's the meal of choice besides
the the standard fish and chips what are
we doing
man it changes a lot to be fair dude it
changes a lot we go from like the
typical freaking
eat your heart out ginormous burger with
like four patties and stuff like that oh
my god
to fight to to the more finer side of
things with like your lamb shanks with
your creamed mash and
mint peas and stuff like that it really
it always big time always
my wife's not a big fan of peas my wife
is a much less pickier than a picky
eater than i am believe me i'm a mess
peas are just like not her things when
you say mint peas i feel like i've heard
that at some point i always forget
that's even a thing
um somebody in the chat actually wanted
to ask and that's a fair question
with the past year and how everything's
going how
how are you guys doing with everything
uh is it a lot of like take out bags is
i mean not at all i mean it is
it's kind of strange so the one thing
that we pride ourselves on
is is the in-house experience you know i
mean so when people come in it's just
making them feel like they're at home
and then they get that nice home-cooked
meal um so for us it's kind of been
come locked down door's shut social
medias go down
everything goes quiet so i mean at the
moment luckily um
the company that sort of owns our
brewery um
is owned by a chinese company and they
are very very wealthy so they are
looking after us
really really well um so yeah so the
family's still good
the home is still cool everything's
everything's good we're just waiting to
reopen now
so that's it blessings brother yeah
because obviously you said you know
the restaurant you know business and
just culinary and in general you we
forget like you know with covid how much
this impacted especially if the
experience is in home like you said
you know in-house so to speak like you
said so um yeah man blessings on that
because that we definitely don't want to
see things go away
for sure for sure what else you gotta
eat uh so
for you as chef obviously doing all this
stuff
um there's a lot of cooking on tv
to different levels you got the british
baking show uh gordon ramsay have
probably watched too many videos and
stuff like that and then master chef and
you see all these different levels
what is like one of your like kind of
bigger cringe things that you know about
cooking behind the scenes
but like anybody on tv that doesn't
really experience
okay that's an interesting question to
be fair because
i i think the working in the kitchen is
is really strange as it's like working
with
food is like probably the most
cleanliest thing that you'll ever
experience in your life but yet the
people that are cooking the food are the
craziest
wackiest people on this planet like
we'll have 120 covers up on the screen
ready for us to start pumping out
and we'd be on the line jamming away to
greece lightning like it's just
no was that it's um it's really strange
i just think that
you can't ever tell the person that's
cooking your food based on the food that
you've got and i think that's the one
thing which
doesn't show in those shows do you know
what i mean because they're all they're
always pristine they're always yes chef
no chef
the kitchen that i run is kind of like
not lapsed but
you should enjoy your job yeah you know
i mean for me i wanted to do youtube i
wanted to do the content creation
because i enjoy it so there's no reason
why my kitchen team shouldn't come to
work wanting to enjoy that so we we have
a right old laugh
it's good fun nice nice and a good
energy that good camaraderie yeah get
that kitchen going that's what's up
what is it okay i know you you got these
guys
i was like as soon as i'm done with food
it's all yours you gotta figure out the
two chefs say that let me let
let me let myself work good so uh for
you two questions
uh favorite dessert and then also just
favorite meal for you to cook
at home okay um
strange but i'm not a dessert guy at all
i i like my savory man okay i like my
savory
ac i don't know why but the
the idea of warm soggy chocolate does
not do nothing for me
no what
is there anything you're good at making
that maybe you don't care to partake in
on the dessert question on the dessert
friend
pro probably not no it's not you
just okay okay it's one of those like
you kind of we're cooking it because
because it's such a passion you kind of
go towards the things that you enjoy
eating primarily
i'm a massive mexican lover i love
mexican food
quesadillas the enchiladas so nice yes
i love a bit of kick nice okay
okay that's that's very unique though
so you didn't even have like a sweet
tooth as a kid like no what about sweets
like that
i mean yeah i guess like sweets and
stuff like that there's always a packet
sweets on my desktop but
as far as any sort of like cakes or
pastries or anything like it's just not
me i don't i don't know
why wow i mean i'm i'm a scrawny guy
trying to put on weights
like that's why you you you've been
disciplined and you're smart
and yeah there's a difference though
he's like i'm gonna take my processed
packaged dessert bites on the side i'm
not gonna like have to spend the time in
the kitchen i'm gonna go buy my sugar
eat it out of a little package and then
you find my way i respect them
listen i ain't got the discipline after
a good meal man
they were like would you like to see the
dessert menu yes
salute the cloud for being disciplined
not partaking and all that
all right i will get done with the chef
stuff but back to you cog i had to
have to get a few because
no i was like i could go way too long
that's why so it's like we got other
things to talk about other people don't
care about food as much as i do but
also it's just one of those things like
for me over the years like experiment
i'm a picky eater so i was like i've
experimented with like my own stuff
so i was like i kind of know what i like
and then i'll find recipes i like so
it's like there's one
i made for my wife before and it's like
it's a miso glaze chilean sea bass i'll
marinate it for a few hours
get in the broiler like maybe 10 minutes
just like
and just little layers of a chili and
cbs like they're thick and
like certain things that i cook and i go
to eat it and then it's like a really
good
like a really good steak at fine dining
certain things when i just like go to
eat it i'm just like
damn this is good it's like you know
that people joke about like an orgasm in
your mouth and i'm like
oh occasionally you get those moments
and i'm like oh and i'm like it's so
good so it's like
i love food so when you say passionate
about it's like when i taught myself to
make cheesecakes and then
you know mini cheesecakes later now
that's a skill that is a skill
cheesecake is a difficulty
it's i will say it's one of the more
annoying ones because
well it's like by the time you have to
like once it's in the oven you're not
just gonna
you're not gonna really do much with it
till the next day so like you there's
not like oh let me let it cool and have
a bite
no you get to let it cool wait for the
next day cool it down
let the pa let it you know contract from
the pan and all that stuff by the time
you get around to a cheesecake it is the
next day i'm like i hope this is good
because i don't know until the next day
so don't go to
i get worried if i go to the restaurant
and the chef is skinny wouldn't want to
go to clown's restaurant
yo they going in shout out to cliffs
i respect you just know if a chef is
skinny he's not stealing the food off
your plate he's sending it to you
exactly never short change for that one
man never
changed no man tremendous man so being
that we transitioned from the uh chef i
think which is pretty amazing
like how are you able to juggle that and
then you know getting into gaming
because i mean i know we talked about a
little bit of your history with the you
know
fps and stuff like that but like how are
we able to
juggle that because now you're now
transitioning now almost into this
full-time youtuber streamer bit like how
does that work for you
it is difficult i'm not gonna lie so um
trying to balance it out is really
really difficult um i try and get as
much time with my kids as i can
with my misses as well having that
one-on-one with your partner is
obviously important as well especially
when you turn around and say i'm gonna
go into the games room for the next six
hours
yes i understand
that one
it's that question are you on tonight
um but yeah i sacrificed a lot of sleep
rather than the rest of my life
um so i'll probably average on three to
four hours sleep a day
oh wow um yeah it is low um
but as far as i'm concerned like people
go to to university or college and
they do all these things to get the
dream job that they want so
why should that be any different for me
you know i mean i need to put that work
in to get our dream job because that's
exactly what it is now
this isn't we're not in a space where
it's 2014 and
you just need to love what you're doing
and you need to work for it now it's
it's people's career lines so um
yeah juggling is is probably the best
way to describe it
because it'll be an hour in here edit a
bit of video jump outside make the kids
lunch go in day it's it's crazy man wow
yeah it's crazy you're pushing you
you're going at it
but respect respect because i know you
got a lot going on and yeah you gotta
even talk about the family
house too seriously like was it four or
five i feel like i'm
miscounting in somewhere i read how many
cats i got
got five kids too wow salute bro
yeah glam for punishment is all i say
man
[Laughter]
you're good you're good that's what's up
you you and your wife got a
magical thing going then to balance you
trying to game then you're being a chef
does she work there too
when you guys yeah she manages the
restaurant she's yeah she's the out
front the face of the company
yeah so all of that and then five kids
i'm like
damn yeah you are very very busy
man but it's impressive to kind of see
you come through
so i know kind of we get a little
background beforehand because we always
ask you a couple questions but when it
comes to
kind of how you got into youtube you
kind of i don't want to say tripped into
it but it just like
became a natural progression of what you
were doing more than anything
right i always say that this was
something that i was built to do it
sounds really dramatic
when you say it like that but it
literally just happened and
it just rolled on through so when we
were doing um
way back in the day with um with my mom
barcode and we were just doing like two
on twos and g infinity and stuff like
that i used my youtube channel as a way
to dispute people cheating
like it was it was uploading those
videos sending it through to
to the main companies that you were
doing the tournaments with and stuff
like that and that's that's kind of how
the channel
like originally started um cloud's
recently that's his first channel i had
cloud receivers
literally and then when i got into
destiny
i said it's just so strange like i just
felt that need to do
tutorials on these quest lines and how
to run this and do that and it just just
happened and it wasn't until
probably the first six months of doing
so and like the views were doing really
well at the beginning and i was like
wait did i'm doing this this is crazy
so i think when when i say that i fell
into it
yeah i literally literally fell into it
it's something i've always
felt that i need to do that's awesome
pretty amazing brother
yeah that's not one of those like oh i'm
gonna go buy my streamer
like webcam green screen package and i'm
gonna do the thing you were like i love
how like
it came from you had to call other
people i wanted the proof
of my tournaments i needed like here's
where you doing this crap
or i did not cheat this is an honest
game that's that's kind of an amazing
way to start a youtube channel and then
later on use it for
something completely different that's
kind of cool now i gotta i gotta talk
destiny with you man because
your history is unique in the sense that
you kind of
fell in the destiny too like you didn't
i mean you knew of it a little bit but
like could you explain how like the
passion for it started because
really your history was kind of
elsewhere the other fps is
and obviously you know cld and stuff
like that but like tell me that that
whole
destiny start when you like okay this is
the game now this is the game
storyline that was that was literally at
characters
and the way that that bungie told a
story
at the beginning of destiny 1 was what
really clawed me in
um and it's it's strange because i think
in destiny 1
it was probably during its his biggest
lackluster in the storyline
because now you must be loving life
because it's probably the best it's been
story
yeah 100 it's really difficult actually
um like listening to like a lot of the
reviews that kind of
slander the game to a degree or push it
so far down when i'm like
dude i'm i'm i'm loving it when they pop
up these random missions and i'm like oh
man this pops into this i'm not a
massive law head i'm slowly getting into
it
but um when they pop up these missions
i'm like dude this ties in with this and
this is going on with this and it's
it's amazing i can spend days i have
spent days
in that hawkmoon quest um so with
destiny 1 it just started off of that
and then
once like the storyline depleted um
it was just about helping people which
again sounds really corny but
um i think towards the end of destiny
one literally do the same thing
yeah a hundred percent it's it's it was
it was kind of like
towards the end of destiny one uh we
started the the live streams on youtube
um and me and my team just ran
raids all day like it was all day we
think we did something like which range
sir which rate so we got it all
right so my favorite raid is wrapping
the machine i'm not going to lie to you
oh good choice that's a first good
choice
that's the first thing in the left i'm
not gonna lie but it was kind of like we
would start the livestream up
the first subscriber would come in and
it'd be like right what raid do you want
to run
and then they'd be like i want to do
this one and i think it was something
stupid like we managed to get
just towards the the second half of the
year in year three um
about 107 to 110 raid carries or
something like that
that's awesome yeah the percentage was
so low that we just kind of wanted to be
able to give people
never forget there was a kid called
spider he was seven
years old man i have never seen people
so damn happy
when they complete these sorts of things
man so it was just trying to up that
percentage rate at the completions
and that really pushed us but um
that's awesome man those are the ones
you hear about like
yeah they said it in chat so i don't
know if you read it and they reminded
you or what but like yeah carrying
somebody through vlog best moment of d1
yeah that's my book yeah
a memorable thing for for the whole team
to be fair that that six-year-old that's
probably now about 14 that we just
haven't seen again
is it it's a memorable part of my move
forward in destiny
that's so cool those are the little the
moments as well it's like there's
like i mean everybody gives like you
know your youtuber your twitch
statements the
it's the moments like that that nobody
ever a lot of people probably won't ever
see or know about
a comment here that somebody says
something actually really nice that you
helped with or
as you said that moment where you helped
a seven-year-old kid in something that
i like and they probably absolutely lost
their mind when
atheon goes down like those are the ones
when you're trying to do something nice
and help or a guide and somebody's like
thank you
i tried this like 20 times i checked out
your like whatever those moments are the
ones i think for me
that oh yeah are part of what keep you
going for so much stuff
because i mean if anybody's ever
thought about this thing the grind is
real and no matter what you're doing in
this man over here grinding chef and
family man of five and i'm yeah
it's a little the small victories that
sometimes hit very big
100 100 percent i definitely agree with
that i think i think it's
that motivational push and i'm massive
into the motivational thing
um i fully believe that like there isn't
anything
that you that you genuinely cannot do if
you put the work in um but you have to
put a work in to succeed in that field
and that's with the people that kind of
comment on the videos or the people
that just leave a nice statement on
twitter or send me a dm that nobody sees
it that's that's that push to just kind
of go right get back to the setup
get back on game and start recording
no it's absolutely bad you're making a
fantastic point it's like because
sometimes you it's that positive
reinforcement right that you need
to be like okay you know what i'm doing
the right thing i'm i'm touching people
people are responding to the content
that that's pretty dope man salute so
you know we got to have a little
subclass question
so uh well i heard you were a hunter at
first i don't know how to feel about
this
you were you were you're gonna be okay
in the end sir you'll be fine
my man is a warlock who who i known them
for but i
uh we found out this this hunter thing
man so we gotta talk about this how did
this
happen so again like i say i
i love the speed i love the mobility the
the sort of zipping around for me back
in destiny one
hunter was that zip around move around
here bounce around there
i it wasn't and to be fair i can put it
on my community for for the move over to
be fair i made a really
really really weird decision because i
saw that java had posted up
something like decide the class that i
made throughout
the next season and i was like you know
what my god he's got a really good idea
with that one i was like screw it we'll
do it as well
and i posted it up and i saw the poll
and i was like
yeah it's going to be a warlock
[Laughter]
i'm a hunter main and a warlock jump was
the worst
idea in my head possible and i just
watched that number go up bro
oh yeah and then once i got on it though
i was like
damn blood this thing is strong
like there is a lot more that i could do
on a warlock than what i could do on a
hunter
and being able to sort of like take in i
play a lot solo
i'm not gonna lie i do play a lot of
solo so with a with a warlock it is
it is definitely substantially easier
being able to do
certain things as a solo player when you
when you're in a warlock that and the
robes just look
dope indeed for some reason i don't know
why i just love it it's drastically for
a reason
how many to ask him how many hunters he
made in d1
oh dude yeah yeah
i went through a phase where i was like
i completed absolutely everything needed
to we won max power on everything we
were just running things for the sake of
running things and i was like
yeah i don't need that titan man i want
to play the game again pop on another
hunter and let's just go oh my god
and then and then i was like okay so
after a little while i was like
i kind of want to play on titan so i'll
delete that hunter again and i'd be back
on the titanic
that went on for a very long time i
think i have totaled out on destiny one
probably about
eight or nine different characters total
jesus
yeah i went went in back then
i started as a hunter for basically d1
through taken king
taken king it's been titan since so i
made my switch
and then i haven't looked back but the
hunter was intriguing at first
and then as soon as like the titan
hammers came out i was stuck
well that's what did it for me like
the hammers and stuff like that always
like with the titans and the warlocks i
find that they always get
like open by i mean up until it stays
the status has been a little bit strange
but
yeah they always get like the the upper
hand as far as supers i feel like
there's a lot more diversity with the
warlocks and the titans
and everything on the hunter just feels
very much samey
there's a lot of similarities between a
lot of the supers so i think that
once i got onto warlock i was like oh my
god i can put down a well i can
i can throw things i can blast people
with
some freaking dragon ball z
beam it's insane i'm like it's just
crazy man there's so many different
things that you can do
right right uh i know you as a solo
player what's one of the hardest solo
things you've had to do in the game
or you think you've done in the game um
one of the
hardest solos that i've ever had to do
was probably voter glass
wow i'm not gonna lie the voter glass
back then was
was a solid now it was a lot of like
one inch positionings that you had to
stand in to make sure that you didn't
hit the dead zone and
it that was probably the hardest thing
i've ever ever really done solo i think
with d2 i kind of like fell off a bit
jumped back in
fell off again played a different game
jumped back in with destiny one it was
like
destiny one was destiny one i just that
was it yeah that was like
my end game so going into afion on your
own was
probably the most challenging thing i've
ever had to do
well that puts my knives to shame so
yeah damn
[Laughter]
okay i agree with that sentiment though
there was something about d1
i know d1 like took me away from a
couple other games here and there and i
don't know it was the games that
released at the time and i know there
are plenty of good ones over the course
of the whole franchise
but something about d1 kept me hooked
more yeah and then i don't know if what
happened in d2 but it was like
nightfalls i haven't done them as much
since just period i haven't done
solo nightfalls as much since and i
don't know if
i there's i don't know if it's
intangible i don't know if it's the
scoring modifiers
whatever it is something changed and
shifted
and then it was like the double
primaries and i'm like it's going to
take me six years to do a nightfall like
it felt like because like you used to
have like specialist nightfall modifiers
cool it's like okay this week's gonna be
solar specialist nightfall
let me work on this combo boss is still
pain on the butt like you had some
like crazy boss fights because you had
like dark blade and shield brothers
and like cool ones in there and then
something shifted in d2 because i'm the
same like i was
d1 like bleeding d1 like
every day and yeah that's where i'd like
you know cut my teeth on and it's like
d2's been
you two hit different on solo type stuff
it's been very strange
and i don't know exactly why
i can't put my finger on it to be
completely honest i can't but it does
feel like a lot of us as far as making
that solo move towards the harder events
have kind of dropped off but i think
it's the people that are doing it
but make more power more power to you
yeah
it's insane watching some of the videos
that go up like oh esoteric puts me to
shame like i
always that's that man is
a beast and then but it is funny you
said like his first video is almost
always a warlock
almost every time his first video will
always be a warlock and then he'll do
what the other one's not saying he can't
but for
speed and like survivability he starts
seems to start there most of the time
yeah definitely i would agree
definitely a lot of survivability there
that's that's cool man good chance this
is so
i know you did say wrath you know what
i'm saying as your favorite raid
why is it your favorite and then if you
got your other top maybe three raids
um i think yeah i'd say wrath of the
machine was probably
probably was my favorite raid but i
think that was probably more to do with
that the memories i've got in it right
rather than anything else i think it is
quite aesthetically pleasing and i love
my black and red you know i i love that
and so the wrapping machine is a hundred
percent
deep staying crypt though coming up
there bro i mean
it is a really really good raid mm-hmm
um i don't i haven't done it a lot
recently i think it's just primarily
because like the loot drop my rng in
that raid was like
so good like i got the the eyes are
tomorrow on run
like so it's been my rng was so good in
there i just
i haven't really had to go in like but i
mean
tomorrow night early you're good you
know
it's really really good but i think that
um as far as mechanics go and stuff like
that
uh dsc is is absolutely insane and kind
of opens your eyes up to
what raiding is going to be in the
future and there's a couple of my mates
which are just going for clears
that's that i mean fair play to him
that's unfortunately that's not me i
need something to grind towards i need a
loot
that that is there waiting for me um and
i think that
that i had like what between my hunter
and my warlock i had both armor sets
plus most of the weapons
before i hit double figures and runs
like it was
it was crazy but um just the rng gods
are shining on you
first time in like four years bro i'll
take it
100 but uh no and i i think the only
other one other than that that i really
uh like really enjoy is it's probably
probably garden to be honest which is a
weird selection but wow i quite enjoy
garden to be fair i think a lot of the
earlier
raids not including like the raid lairs
quite honestly
i think a lot of days to be lacklustered
for me
personally and i can't put my finger on
why because last wish is a lot of
people's selection but yet
i don't know i just really didn't laugh
at that
okay so i was gonna say like vault and
king's fall
crota that stuff's more towards the
bottom of your list uh
crota is really close to the bottom of
my list to be honest
good morning um it is it's a circle it's
a strike
good you're welcome
every character on all difficulties like
it was
the easiest thing ever he's disgusted
with you
he said how did he miss merch the great
crota i don't i don't know i know how
this keeps
you keep preaching wrapping the machine
was uh not for the machine sorry king's
full
um i was really fine now i'm not gonna
lie i really enjoyed king's fall
oh but i just yeah i just i just think
that
it kind of opened everything up as far
as raiden so everything that we're doing
now
probably wouldn't be the way that it was
if foot didn't exist
that's probably a good point yeah um so
for me
i like king saul because of what it's
done for us as far as raiding
um but my dude if i get given another
gun that is gonna kill me
i'm gonna go mad oh yeah i hate when
they do that
i'm glad you mentioned that i really
hate because zombo's kind of
gets us into that you know the the what
is what's supposed to do that damn gun
toucher malice that's the one yeah and
it's like
i hate when they kind of get into that
mindset weapon design-wise
where you have things like that and then
tommy's matchbook that's like i don't
want any weapon
that's going to be hurting me while i'm
shooting like you know what i'm saying
so i'm with you on that because it's
like
it was so specific and it's like you're
really not going to use it
anywhere else
it was kind of you obtained it there for
that alone
right so it's just kind of like a little
bit frustrating i remember with tommy
smashbook i literally got it read the
description i was like ah that looked
cool in the vault
i'm gonna go ahead and go ahead and set
this scene here it's gonna look nice on
the display case
i didn't even shoot tommy's badge once i
read the description i was like
i don't think i pulled the trigger on
that thing but maybe yeah
i don't want to see him around for a bit
but yeah
no i've it's never been that appealing
yeah
there's enough other things in the game
that wants to kill you i don't need to
do it myself i don't need to help
them out and be like hold on let me make
my health low so if you
get me wrong yeah
especially in pvp if you ever get killed
by and you see that in the in the bar
you're like but
how the hell are you doing there
how was that not a trade like this crazy
absolute salute another question i have
for you just in reference to
um consecration was the name how did the
whole
cloud plays come together ah
so every originally and it's a really
like
when i think about it now the the my
original name was really dramatic like
literally it was like dynamic
force or something like that it was it
was
yeah it was an immovable object
unstoppable
dynamic force
but when when i came out of like the um
like the semicomps or
starting call of duty in that i decided
to hit a rebrand and
really hone in on on on youtube as far
as being able to
design a brand rather than just sound
like a tank right um and uh
i i've i'm not gonna like i vape a lot
a lot of vape a lot so okay okay the
word cloud
resonated quite well that makes more
sense now yeah makes sense now it's
coming together i'm i'm a big old vaper
so
i'm just sat there with my boys i'm
vaping away and i'm like
hold that damn phone bro
i can i can name myself after my vape
and it was literally that that simple it
just kind of
rolled in bro and from that point of
yeah i see a lot of people do a lot of
rebrands and stuff on twitter
no i don't i think once you've decided
your name and you've gone for
gone for your pushes your alias like
keep that go
oh yeah yeah once you're you're you're
stuck
100 100 like i am ubontis until i die at
this point it is not gonna change
nobody's gonna switch that up i will be
the cheetah
and evontis but i will say vape juice
plays doesn't quite have the same ring
to it
because it doesn't quite roll off the
tongue
yeah that's probably the safer bet and
yeah
yeah i'm still feeling dynamic force
but it was when i designed it it was
like 2014 2015 or something like that
and like back then it had to have a
number in it so it was dynamic force
but with a one instead of one it made no
sense
at all at least that was the dynamic
force 79
you're you're you're okay x
dynamic 469 x x or something like
that's totally everybody's most people's
name and that's why i was like
mine is a goofy store and you're not
getting it right now but mine i love
mine is so like nobody has mine so i was
like
i'm very unique yes yeah very unique
mm-hmm again handle so it's really easy
when it
yeah yeah 100 100
well we've got this whole game destiny
yep
a little bit here and there i think the
community's been talking about more of
the game
yes then they've been playing it lately
yeah yeah even you've got your video
about all right
about 12 minutes we're gonna talk about
some drama and i was like yes
i was like yeah we go through these
cycles of
people leaving the game and coming back
and the ups and the downs of content
creators and stuff like that
and you said it pretty well in one of
your videos for some it's their job
so it's like depending on what they're
doing depending on you know how things
are going and stuff like
some people have been doing it for a
while some people are have been
making lives out of this thing but yeah
we definitely have our ups and downs and
right now the community definitely seems
like it's in
kind of a down state so a little bit
yeah
i find it really strange though so like
my mentality on it is is obviously
have push your opinion but
without killing the game that you are
currently promoting
like at least push some positivity
because it's not
all bad there is a lot of bad in there
but i think you need to acknowledge
and i think um ink if one has mentioned
it um during one of his videos he said
he needs to start or i think he's
even in the podcast or something like
that he needs to start with the positive
part
because once people hear the negative
that's it yeah
so it's and it's it's kind of one of
those so
i just it baffles me when people leave
i'm like
they'll be back in a couple of months
that doesn't work
destiny is one of those drawback games
yep um it's
it's more the basis of the way that the
game is and the way that the game is
played
and after the amount of years that we've
been
dealing with bungie as a company and as
a team like
we can shout as loud as we want they
will do 90
of what they want to do like roll with
it
or take some time out like
with d2 i'm not the same way in d1 like
d1 all i did was play destiny that's all
i did
d2 has given me sort of like that lapse
time to play some other games with some
mates and
and and just sort of in enjoy gaming
again
rather than going right okay i need to
do this for the content i need to do
this for the content i mean don't get me
wrong like that's still there but i'll
get on
i'll sit down with my boys right what
are we doing today we'll go and do this
this and this record for the video i'll
get all that video out of the way and
i'm like right
close application what we're doing now
let's go and play some rainbow six
let's go ahead and just go and play
something else you know what i mean
so it's got its positives and it's got
its negatives and i think destiny is a
community
it's a really a really vocal community
vocal minority for sure like the content
creators of the like
destiny twitter is such a small piece of
the vast player base like we have our
friends that we connect with and stuff
like that and there's so many people
that don't
you know follow all the youtube scene
and read the twab every week and
probably much less have a clue what's
going on they might just see like a
pop-up in destiny and things like that
and
i'm not assuming people saying people
don't pay attention to it but there's
people who definitely don't
pay attention to the content creators as
much so they're just like hey there's
the new hawkmoon mission came out or
something like that they might see an
article that
you can get random roles now little
stuff here and there but it's like most
of us when we break things down to
i don't know doing a two-hour podcast
about the game every week they probably
don't like
most people if they're listening even if
they're listening to our podcast you
know they're hardcore for sure
mm-hmm facts facts good point i mean
you know we obviously there's a lot to
talk about and um there's also
uh a big subset what i find out is a big
subset of
gamers that are playing destiny that
have completely oblivious
to these problems that the hardcore are
talking about
and they are just so happy with the game
and they're loving and stuff like that
but i do feel like it's it it's the
hardcore it's us
that are having these problems which is
fine we are allowed to complain but
in the scope of things i think that
people don't realize
how small that number actually is
comparison to everyone else that's still
playing
because i'm seeing people on my friend's
list just getting lament now just
finishing campaign now
and i'm just like wow you know what i'm
saying they're having a blast kind of
thing so
it is interesting but we got a lot to
talk about this uh
12 right yeah man well
for two of us we can talk about the
first part of the 12 one guy
just did not get around to it
jesus i mean i do have a heart mood i
mean i do have one
well look at this man shaving people
yeah continue
[Laughter]
it's friday morning we're here
around the campfire and some of us
have experienced this harbinger mission
yes um but that was the big deal like
last week there was this like hey shoot
the fireplace with your hawk moon
hey you can go wander around these
little like back things and stuff like
that
and then this week we're like is it oh
wait there's a there's a hot fix
there's a patch and everybody's like all
right where is it what's going to happen
so of course uh the mission did actually
open up
there is a quest over at the crow if you
go pick up his pericausal feather quest
you get to go in
and the hilarious part for about the
first 20 minutes everybody goes into the
mission is like all right where do i go
there you go we're standing on this like
outside of
the the building wall like
where the hell do i just like the dam is
too far
and then some people with like warlock
sword flying were probably the first
ones to get over there and i'm like
and i was watching fallout at the same
time as i was looking too and he was
he had the same exact idea and i was
like he's like there is no way they're
gonna make cloud
not cloud sorry
they're gonna make warlock sword flying
the way you have to get to this landing
and everybody's like
this doesn't make any sense what the
hell like there's gotta be a better way
and then sure enough people just start
jumping across and you can land over on
the dam and you're like oh
damn it so
jumped in there was a nice twist though
yeah like i think being so far away is
something that they don't do very often
like that i thought that was quite cool
yeah there's one branch and it's
magically pointing you in the right
direction when we figure it's the one
lit up branch and you're like oh that
seems to stand out a little bit now that
you look at it but
at first i was up there like i can't
tell i went back into the truss land i
jumped around and went back in the wrong
direction
i yeah it's
it's been fun to watch yeah aries came
in and helped me with my run because
yeah soloing that thing the first time
through is a bit dicey
yeah i can imagine i haven't done that
yet that's still on my checklist i need
to need to go into that solo
i need to but yeah first time i went and
i was like oh how's this and the enemies
like tagged me one time i was like
damn what level are these guys it's 1270
like
secret mission at 1270 definitely starts
off pretty quick but
uh for you cloud like when you see these
type of missions like
random secrets come up stuff like that
like i know you're kind of like me
you're like solo player something unique
kind of cool
this is gonna be the stuff that gets you
excited right 100
100 so the typical definition of me
is i love farmable content i don't know
why i enjoy content that i can
repeatedly play until i'm blue in the
face
but i love flammable content so things
like the whisper mission i love it
i think it's like did you like your
mission
forges no okay didn't didn't really like
forges too much i think it's
i think it's the the mystery behind it
so these last few weeks for me the
hawkmoon quest
has just been awesome like i've just
been roaming around with specific things
like
i need to find something else like i
love that they're teasing it but they're
not
actually saying they're teasing it yeah
it's it's really
i don't know not knowing as well as
knowing
is is awesome for me and then being able
to play through that mission
i mean we did it like five six times
just in like a couple of hours last
night
um just to keep going through it until
you get that run that random roll which
hits just
right i don't know i love that sort of
stuff that and these sorts of missions
that you can
just drop a stream and help those people
who can't get through it
or don't have the friends to get through
it and that's the sort of stuff that
enjoyment
oh yeah like once i've like practiced
solo and i helped
aries helped me the first time because i
was just like stuck but after i went
back like the second time i was like all
right let me take it slow
think about a build and then now i've
done it like
multiple times through and it's it it's
a nice bounce because
there's a couple places where it can be
a bit dicey but then once you kind of
figure it out you're like oh i'm able to
manage it and this is actually
a fairly easy one to guide through once
you know it's coming
it's like it's not too crazy there's no
timer first
right i just want to say that's probably
one of the biggest pieces is
it's not time constrained now there's a
triumph for doing in 15 minutes
okay is there does it cap at 50 i've
heard people saying that it didn't take
me 15 minutes to do this but i got that
implemented
so i agree because i was sitting in the
mission when i got to
um trying to think who i had somebody
come in and we were trying to run
through it together
and then we got to a certain point
they're like hey i have a friend that
wants to come too
and they joined like at the first main
fight
because there's two we did that got to
the box room finished up
and somehow we got the triumph and i was
like what
because i don't think it's triggering
correctly either because i swear we were
sitting there
trying a couple things had somebody else
come and be like hey they were like 12
30 so we dragged them through
they were dead most of the time but
however it worked like we still got that
i'm like
that didn't feel like 15 minutes now i
don't know where the timer starts from
if it's just the boss fight itself
i don't know but yeah that it's it's a
weird trigger i think
yeah i don't know how it triggers to be
honest i watched um
scaro do his first run and he his first
run was a solo flawless
like i don't know how the hell my guy
does stuff like that but that definitely
took
longer than 15 minutes but still came
out with the emblem at the end so i
don't know where the trigger point is or
if it's bugged or not there's a few bugs
in there
yeah yeah it's interesting man
yeah man but it didn't like i was gonna
say like cognito for like
what have you got to it so far you know
i mean i just literally started the very
very beginning where you know you have
to shoot the
per you know and this [ __ ] i seen all
these people standing in one spot like
this has got to be in the trunk
you know i just went in there dived
through there and it definitely gave me
get kind of gave me
zero hour feels a little bit at first
and then um
you know when i saw the big you know
damn and scaling and stuff like that i
didn't realize okay it's just branch
and stuff like that and then um i did
see a video on it i mean obviously
yours and you know what you call it but
um
yeah i mean those type of missions i
always do like you know because
kind of completes some stuff narratively
with crow as well as
you know let's be honest like this is a
unique thing with hawk moon like we
didn't
expect anything like this with an exotic
in terms of
random roles right and and on some level
you know it's fixed and then it's you
know experimental on the level
but i thought it was cool i thought it
was cool you know having the thing uh
having a reason to farm it and then
obviously you know you got the ship in
there looking really cool
so you know this season we've had our
issues
overall i feel you know i'm
dying we're going to talk about what
we're going to talk about next but
tonight about what's the next chapter
but
for me a decent way to end you know i
mean not not
super crazy crazy not you know oh my god
it's the most amazing but it's not
terrible either i thought i thought it
was solid i thought it was solid just
right right what did you feel like now
that we're coming
towards the end of the season wrapping
up with something like this
i think for me um i think that coming
towards the end of the season
it was enough it wasn't like it didn't
blow me out of the water
right but it was enough um i think when
if you were to ask other people
and i'm sure we'll see videos about it
in the oncoming weeks
but um yeah i i think that
i think that missions like that always
bring out a different sort of player and
i think that
you're never going to keep everybody
happy so if they hadn't brought that out
and they'd have brought out a random
activity which
gave you an emblem and a shader and
somebody else would have loved that but
we would have had it
so i think you're never going to keep
anybody happy with that that's the
problem with communities man so
i really enjoyed it i think it was
enough to end the season on but
now let me ask both of you this both of
you that you've completed
you know he and i have at length had our
issues at one point with hawkmoon
returning as you well know
but now my question now that it's it's
here random roles
catalyst i'm assuming both of you have
maxed this thing out and have
got your catalyst done i know what the
catalyst does i haven't finished it yeah
it's pretty cool you didn't get the
catalyst
two people on this podcast didn't get
the catalyst
anyway let me continue on but we played
the content man
i mean i was like
shot's fine i like that i like when a
guest is like
what i like that i like that like he
held you down
he shot back that was good that's good
i think the opinion on the hormone is
weird though in it mm-hmm okay
i think that the random roles has opened
up for a lot on exotics
i think it has opened up for a heavy
future on where exotics are going to
lead to
um so i have a whole thought about this
that came up in my podcast last night
okay yeah see the hawk means it i've got
a really
like dodgy opinion on it i love what i
have to do to get it
right but but for me it's a hell of a
long-winded
way to give me a weapon that on
playstation on d1 that i was just
essentially given
like i did do you know so i mean
if so okay so satisfaction level
cloud play in its final form
or what you assume to be right when you
guys can beat your catalyst
and go super saiyan yeah like
are you satisfied with this
version of it
i'm satisfied with the version of what
it does
the bit that disappoints me is that it's
still a hawk moon
i think that they could have done what
they did with like the red death where
we had the crimson with a slightly
entwining difference like a bit of
effort
rather than just throwing it back in
there and going this has got random
rolls i'm like yo i love the random
rolls
but i'm still holding a gun that i held
like
years ago i'm i'm all i'm all for like
the whole recycling and content is
content
um but for a weapon that that i obtained
so damn easily in d1
i don't think should have been such a
difficulty for people to obtain in d2
so your issue is more the difficulties
of of obtaining
as opposed to the weapon itself
i'm talking about the weapon itself as
far as paracausal shot
having to shoot as many times that's
what i mentioned this is
just you know where you're at with the
new hawk boat
i haven't got a catalyst done so i can't
give his full push on it but it felt a
hell of a lot stronger in d1
okay okay fair enough fair enough e
where are you at with this uh send your
way if it is here we go getting comfy
that's good baby here it comes like
there's a couple things about this first
and you said random roles on an exotic
and i was actually thinking about this
talking with chat last night new rattle
no because he was there
before i think it's my thoughts on this
whole thing it's how a random roll
exotic works
collections don't function as we wish
they would if you go pull an exotic from
collections
or this one specifically you get the
trans figure whatever the perk is that's
a question mark
now here's the question
if this is seasonal content and it only
lasts a year
and you go to which queen and you don't
have any in your vault you're only going
to be able to pull the question mark
ever that's a good question i didn't
think of that it's literally like we
were looking through it
and somehow it came up and we're like i
wait
so if for some reason
either like your ability to get random
roles
on this weapon one that doesn't have a
question mark theoretically will go away
after which queen if this is seasonal
mm-hmm because that's like because the
collections all work as
you're like even the kiosk seems to tend
to match like what so i'm like
i honestly what and that brings up a
better question of
if this is a path for some future
exotics to be random
you do need finally a way for your
collections to be like i want to lock a
random role
to my collections like that needs to
function because it is
it's an exotic it's not going away right
no it's it's
it's a good point it's a good point i
mean maybe the
base question mark version
becomes the you know the placeholder but
for those who missed out again
i'm not i don't know how they're gonna
handle it and at some point the problem
with they find themselves when you're
making a good point is at some point
one would assume you know that that
mission is not going to be around
forever
so how do they handle the random
or is it just gonna be random in in rng
in addition to you getting the exotic
like
it drops as a random thing and then it
randomizes that random perk
it's an interesting conundrum for them
to have but yeah
well you'll have yeah then you have some
people that farm it and if it's like oh
if collections
is just random i'm gonna pull seven
rolls later on to get the one i want to
like
how it's a weird precedent that it sets
which is
because exotics currently are not going
away they're not sunsetting if they do
the community is going to have another
explosive we don't want that right
because we don't want that right
right i mean
trust me the way it's the way it's
handled right now no we've been
bombing yeah the way it's handled right
now no
because we had this previous discussion
when the theory of sun setting was a lot
better than the way it's been
implemented because right now
we've had that you know like this is not
this is not done well
i was pro sunsetting when they first
announced it i was
bringing it up i predicted and died on
this hill
and then and then they absolutely like
they were carrying the cake out to the
table
they tripped and face-planted into the
cake
i mean that's allergy last week last
week
i started the twab and i literally was
like the word reissued started a bullet
point and i did not want to keep reading
because i'm like oh
son of a i know where this is going i'm
like last week hurt
for me and i know a lot of the community
like read that and said
uh and i've said on the podcast before
when i see a reissued go figure anywhere
on a list i'm going to lose my ever
loving mind like it's over
because that's my like 45 000 kill
weapon from forsaken that i had like
so many so like we're all gonna have one
if like if i see this again
i'm gonna be pissed but no like that was
the weird thing about random roles i was
like for hawkmoon if this mission is
seasonal and then which queen somebody's
like hey what's that cool
opening shot hawkmoon that you've got
with like a heavy grip and they're like
well you can go pull that random one
with a polymer grip and a question mark
that doesn't do you any good like
the collection theoretically is never
going to be as good so it was like that
was a weird one for me
first another thing that i was actually
thinking about on the hawkmoon
is the catalyst what it does for some of
you guys that don't know
gives you two more bullets in the
magazine i believe and also gives you a
small boost of stats
the stats aren't bad that's fine yeah
but i was thinking as i've been playing
like
other games and like progression and
leveling up and this is where
bungie is always like we can't make
anything too powerful because
in a pve sake of those other two bullets
if you could hit because you max at
paracasal seven you cannot go higher i
go faster
you just get like forgiveness bullets if
this is a game for pve that you could be
a little bit more powerful
you could get to perocl times nine and
go smash some people in the face with an
exotic
but because it's destiny because you
can't be too strong
they're like hey we'll give you some
forgiveness you can't make this gun any
better and that was just like one of
those little things for me that i was
like
i always there's always a little bit
more that they're they're holding back
from because they're like oh i can't be
too over the top it can't be like
borderlands the gun would have like para
causal time 7 000
for an example but like this it's like
they'll give you forgiveness but like
they figured out where their damage
numbers they're okay with and they stop
so it's i don't know i wonder if that's
one thing that
i always find really strange with
destiny and that's one thing that never
really resonates too well with me
i think that when you go into other
games like you say like
there's always an op weapon or you watch
call of duty as in
um pro scrims or just like cod champs or
something they all run the same weapons
because they are the best weapons in the
game to utilize for that specific thing
i i don't see the bad side of if there
being weapons that are
extremely overpowered as long as there's
a an event
before it that is is for those people
who are extremely good at the game
that makes sense to me um but
i i don't know i i think destiny
community's concept on balancing is
really weird because it's kind of like
well
i don't have that god roll so i want my
gun to be as strong as that
right but that's that's just not how the
game works i think it's a really
really weird uh really weird play style
as far as the game goes because you kind
of need to put
time into it to pull out from it right
so for casuals it's really difficult and
i understand that but
it's one of those games isn't it right
yeah no i hear where you're coming from
is they're in a tough spot
and a tough spot again you know because
most games like a borderlands or these
other games you know
they don't have that pvp component so
you know
now you become it becomes a whole you
know age-old issue with the
double balancing right should it be
split you know pvp versus pve and i
thought at times they've tried to
navigate it
you know semi-okay where they say hey
we're not going to make it we just did
this change is only going to affect pvp
but then sometimes we've seen
subconsciously where they make a change
you know
case in point you know like the warlock
stasis um
melee you know when i got nerfed you
remember cloud i got nerfed and i'm just
like man this is useless now like you
know because of the pvp complaining
it really affected me in pve and i just
i wasn't really so it
they always are going to be in that
tough spot to your argument
with um op weapons so to speak
i'll give them some credit you know um i
want to give some credit because i don't
think
we're giving lament and eyes
a lot of credit i think lament is really
beasty i'm in there
like it's a joke like i i'm in there
gambit
one time to throw the bubble down i run
inside the bubble
and i go hammed it up
you know the thing it's just like you
know a tracks you know in the in the
raid
give them the business it's few things
unless the boss is
aerial or at a distance right
if that boss is in your circumference
and you got it's a bunch of y'all with
lament
like i want to get him credit like i
felt i was surprised lament does what it
does
to be honest i was like yo
is so crazy that i'm like yeah we might
have to
this might be a beyond light weapon that
next season
look
on some level and now i'm like okay you
would say i catch you again no no i mean
that's exactly what they do and i forget
i was looking at there's probably one
other thing i'm probably going to talk
about here in a minute oh i know what it
is uh but that's the idea is like
when it comes to currencies they'll be
stingy
at the first part of the season and then
they'll be like okay you can have a few
more
but on the other side new stuff they'll
be like hey this will be powerful
and then we've got to cut it off at the
knees and make it so weak you don't want
to use it
there's as like and somehow it's like
they they don't ever start they don't
ever start in the middle they start on
either side and be like all right let's
make it
currencies are going to be slow we're
going to like extend this drip feed as
long as we can
and then on the other side here's like
crazy stasis exotics
okay those have been fun for a little
while now let's kind of balance
everything out and bring things to like
a medium
yeah yeah yeah to me it reminds
it's like a parent to be they're a
parent it's like
we'll let them have that fun this season
but we're gonna stop that
next season like that's over with you
know what i'm saying and it's it's tough
man
it's tough because you know you do have
fun and community loves it
and they want to get out in front and
and really do things like that and go
crazy you know what i'm saying so just
like
you know and then you know to their
argument they've always said you know
they don't like creating things like
what was that thing that was just
oh it was awful the bridge and there was
gambit oh right
recording yeah so it's like we have
things like reckoning right where
you're getting sniped from all these
crazy angles and all this stuff going on
just to combat all the supers and the
wells and the stuff like that
they're in a tough spot they're in a
tough spot with that it's just
unfortunately to give and go the nature
of game balance
and the problem is they're kind of
they're kind of um guilty to their own
creation
they only have to like in the sense of
they create these awesome things and
have these amazing ideas and we eat it
up like
yo that's crazy that's amazing and then
when it comes to now
real life implementation they feel to
themselves okay man damn man we went a
little bit
too you know we had to scale it back a
little bit it's
it's tough man i really i don't i just
naturally assume that's the push and
pull
of destiny batman that's just how i look
at it but i know a lot of guys don't
like it
i think if they kind of looked at it on
a basis where they said oh
that's a bit too powerful we got to pull
it back a little bit i would
i would like respect i like you were
saying like having that medium whereas
they just come down with an iron fist
smash it into the floor and it's like
there's no middle point where they go
okay look at these statistics these are
well let's just drop it a little bit and
see what happens
like it's just a solid crack in the
teeth
right okay well i'm changing my loadout
yeah you're just changing it and
here's my issue now is the problem then
becomes then you have all these things
that
have been victimized by the hammer right
mashed into the ground
and then sometimes they never revisit it
again
yeah so now this thing that was once
beloved renowned
dominant is useless hello sleeper
simulant hello sleeper simulator
oh my god sleeper simulant you know what
i'm saying it's like i remember all the
work i did to get that and i'm like
can we ever get a bump and that that
weapon was nerfed because of one game
mode
cause a gambit it got nerfed like three
times because of gambit
that's a screen breaker same thing oh
exactly
and my thing is it's like okay you they
have to have
a mutual cloud that's what they got to
do you got to have the usage rates on
these
guns you know what's not being used no
more
right we all know ain't nobody busting
out done the lord like that no more
ain't nobody remember what the law was
was the king at one point
so it's like now it's like okay let's do
something
to these exotics or these things that
are not getting used anymore there's no
need to keep them completely
destroyed because a new player gets it
and i have to tell them
they're like yo i just got this thing
y'all are like what you got you know i
got such-and-such i'm like ah nah that's
not that's not it no more that's not
matter no man don't worry about that put
that in the void i'll tell guys
put it in the vault that's that's not it
you know kind of thing do you got this
oh yeah hold on to that
that's good but it just sucks because
you you see that time and time
often but you would say any i'm sorry oh
i don't even know now
okay i'm sorry i don't know photography
no but it was just like it's
yeah the
a lot of people look back at their time
and especially destiny two
more of some of the funnest moments when
things are
kind of busted kind of broken those a
lot of the time
feel like some of the standout fun
moments when things are
they have an op moment they have a
busted feel they have
laser tag and crucible is probably not
the best example but it's still one
everybody remembers that was fun
even it was like this is an absolute
mess
there was an el there's an emblem for it
so it's like obviously a lot of people
partook
but either way it was like hawkmoon on
the catalyst is one of those where i'm
like
it's fine i was like but i'm with like
clout i was like for me it's like a
different reason i think
that i would want it to be because like
now you've got like your pericausal shot
now for a cloud it's like hey this was
an easy gun that was given to me if i'm
gonna earn something through a secret
mission stuff like that
maybe it's not hawkmoon maybe it has a
feel to it but as you said like crimson
and red death like
you could do a you know a throwback a
good a
feel about the gun be like hey we've got
a randomness to the bullets there's some
or there's
you know a little different nature to
the gun and give like a reason how
but it's not quite the same as opposed
to giving it hawkmoon and
that's just like me wanting a different
gun like now how it feels like
now it's got a high skill ceiling that
people in crucible who can like start
stacking
theoretically some people are going to
be good enough to like one tap supers
with this thing now which is gonna go
out here yeah it's like there are people
who are
strong with the weapon absolutely it's
like it's a high skill
gun now and it's one of those that for
some people are really going to enjoy
um so i don't think it's a bad weapon
i think for me it's still just calling
it hawkmoon
and just the originality of going
through for that
do i think it's a bad gun now no i never
said it was going to be
and i think the way they implemented it
is is a unique way like
when you're going through the mission
like if i'm working on my catalyst as
i've been helping people and you go bing
bing bing bing bing bing
49 000 on a bullet that actually feels
pretty good
i'm going to do this come on oh ho boom
wasn't doing none of this in pvp
i get i'm so i'm saying but i was like
yeah so it's like is it a bad thing in
general
no i think hawkmoon's kind of a unique
thing in itself and it's actually got
some power in some places so
you cover hole he's coming home i love
this right here come on brother come on
but i'm i'm still on the point of like
you could have the hawkmoon aesthetic
the look the feel
and i've heard yeah i was like you know
don't call it don't call it don't damn
well i feel you i know i don't feel like
birds
[Laughter]
whatever stupid name similar aesthetic
like a
reference to what it was you know that
type of thing where we've like
built up a gun so it's like overall it's
like hawkmoon they did decent with it
but it's like going through the
as you said it's like for me it was like
it wasn't a brand new mission like
whisper
because we had gone through like we had
gone through and done it we've been some
places we saw some things
and all we did is get a slightly harder
version with some new stuff
so it was like it wasn't like a whisper
or a zero it was like a
i think paul tesley said it was like a
1.5 hawkmoon one point like the way the
story mission was done so it was like it
was
it was decent but it didn't live up to
the top of like their secret missions
but it was a nice thing to experience as
well it was like i'll still take
something obviously this still got some
unique to it a cool little solo run
stuff like that
is a lot better than obviously
way better than you know some of the
stuff we've had hopefully i just want to
give a point shout out to
holly bob in chat areas he said an
interesting point he said one thing that
i always wonder is if they never nerf
things like sleeper
would they still be used with the great
stuff that's come out
that's better like lament what's your
guys thoughts on that
i mean they're here cloud you go because
you go i was talking
i i i don't know i think i think there's
things like sleeper i think they've got
a really good reputation
and sometimes i think that a reputation
can outweigh the gun
and i think the sleeper is very very
good but i think with these new weapons
that they bring out they get brought out
with such power for a reason
um and i feel like the lament would
still overpower the sleeper
it's top form and just because they they
want that turnover
but not so much that they'll give us a
load more weapons but
fair enough fair enough to be up there
but yeah
okay i mean i think that's
i do like lament like damage wise
outshines a lot of stuff right now
and that just kind of gives a point to
where many exotics
both armor and weapons need a revisit
yes if they're gonna stay in there's a
lot of armor that people are like
like school of dire ahamkara if they
don't want it to function where it gives
you back 100
of your super when you know the bomb how
often do you get the nova bomb like 30
guys
you don't but if you do guess what you
had the right moment you had the exotic
on and you get your nova bomb right back
if you know of obama boss you're not
going to get it back so it's like
they're
and if they just hate that functionality
give it another change they've done it
with a couple but there are so many that
are sitting on shelves collecting dust
and vaults
or just in collections that people don't
even want to pull out
because they they had some fun they got
nerfed
and they haven't been revisited again so
there's a lot of guns out there like
that
so it was like sleepers one of those
that aesthetically is amazingly cool
had it like if there's a point
i mean it takes some thematically if we
ever get a point where we do any
interactions with rasputin's
exo shell or whatever we're going to do
with him that'd be a good time to be
like
hey by the way we updated sleeper give
it like a thematic like
revisit or something i don't know but i
was like there's a lot i'm with you it's
like there's a lot that
could come back to their heyday and
still probably
be more in line and not opie to other
stuff i agree i agree
yeah man that's what the run that value
but we got more twive
a lot of stuff kicking off man it's a
slob
so funny if you say that for people who
don't know what you're talking about
this weekend
or 12 and they're like i'm sorry what'd
you say
so they have the next point is like
we're talking about sticking around
basically this is last year was all
about fomo was a big issue be like oh if
you missed this season you didn't get to
see
saint come back into the tower you
didn't get to see the corridors of time
which i
got those are so cool um there's things
that were in the game
that left three months later
so now we have a weird conundrum and i
wanted to ask you guys about this is
we'll kind of cover some of the bits
here
but the idea is they're saying
everything's going to stay around for
the year of the expansion
so right now season of the hunt stuff is
going to be here until witch queen which
we don't have a
date on but we'll get to that lineup
later bit but the idea is you take
season 15
that's still gonna have a three month
life theoretically
so like whatever you get in like the
last season before the expansion
that stuff's not staying around any
longer than it did before so i wondered
if you guys
or as a developer if you're just like oh
you got season 50 and stuff and
developers like
damn it like they don't want this stuff
that's enough
but i was like they don't want stuff
that's in the game for three months i
want the stuff that's going to be in the
game for a year with more life and
a chance to revisit and balance and
stuff three months it's like throw it in
if it's good or not then we're moving on
like
i wonder if you guys have any thoughts
of how bungie's gonna treat content
now that it stays around longer that
like 14 and 15
versus like 13 and 12 like how is that
gonna feel do you guys think i was kind
of curious
would you feel clout i in all honesty
just as soon as i feel like i know i i
then
never have a freaking clue how it's
gonna work like
like i said i was pro sunset to begin
with and now it's here
i'm like dude take it away take it away
take it away
like so when we start talking about like
cross format in seasons
um i don't know man i'm unsure because i
feel like it's a season for a reason
otherwise why have we got seasons if
everything's gonna mingle and mash
until a certain point what's what's the
why what the hell is the point
like it just doesn't make any sense to
me let me ask you this
where do you think they're gonna fall
say we're six months ahead
we're in or maybe five months whatever's
gonna follow us there
we're in season 14 new person comes into
the game
they get beyond light and they're
experiencing be like all right we're in
season 14 i'll buy that
how do you think they're going to handle
hunts at that point
do they have to go buy a discounted
season 12 to go experience
it is it now just in the game as part of
your normal experiences
these are weird questions that i've been
kind of wondering about like how do they
handle your
old seasonal content that somebody
bought because you have to buy seasonal
hunt right now for 10
which some people are like uh really
then later on like is it still
locked out of like you can't go do the
crow hawkmoon stuff
and so you buy that old season that's
like six months old now is that
how do you how would you like it handled
how do you think it's going to be
handled
this this is what this is why i find it
strange with how we've got dlcs which
have seasons inside of it
so if you look at a lot of other games
they all have that same season aspect
whether it's call of duty or
fortnite jesus christ um
what was that for all right i got that
thing just
it flashbacks so many bad flashbacks of
fortnight where i just felt
a hell of old getting crumbled by 13
year olds
every time thinking about it
but even with all of that like a season
is a season and anything before that
point
is inaccessible because it's the
relevant season
a lot again this is why destiny is a
weird aspect because we've got dlcs
with seasons inside of it so you pay for
the dlc
and then you pay for the seasons inside
of it so it's kind of strange on how it
would work i mean if they wanted to do
it so they just went
the dlc is a dlc as the things we
released at the beginning
will still be there at the end then
that's that's
that's that that's their decision but
it's just kind of the things at the end
of the season
still format to a lower time period
don't i say
i don't know how i feel about it i just
kind of take it as it comes
and make my decisions on individual
activities based on how long they're
there and stuff like that i
don't i don't ever want to say it or
work right i really don't
because i think if one thing that
destiny do is they make things work that
you think wouldn't work
and then they make things flop that you
think would work well back
thanks i'm there i don't know what to
think about this this is
a surprise i did not see this one coming
mainly because i felt they've been
preaching this whole
uh what is it dcv the the uh that's the
content involved
well it's like they have mentioned this
before they said they the fomo has been
mentioned previously
right as like a thing but yeah the whole
vault it's like you can keep going but
it's like i know this was mentioned
before it's kind of an idea but this is
the first time we're
kind of seeing how it's going to
function right yeah because
for me i i mean because of the way
they've been doing things prior right
you know fractal line warming cell
mission stuff seasonal stuff
you know as soon as that new season
starts you're accustomed to you show up
in the tower the next day that stuff's
gone
right so now i don't want to get into
prismatic with castle we'll get there
but yeah
you know um you know with rathborn hunts
right so now i go to the tango shore
we got an explanation that we will
explain about why someone
is where they are where they shouldn't
be
but you know now there's gonna be i'm
assuming some form of a kiosk or some
form of
whatever right screen so
how does the new player like you said e
interact with this you know how is he
pushed to do that if pushed at all you
know
that that is my q i understand the
reasonings for
um fomo and you know
not getting people wanting to miss out
and stuff like that
so it's it's just weird i don't i'm i'm
literally where cloud is at cloudplay
i'm like i don't want to say this is not
gonna work
because i don't know you know what i'm
saying but at the same time it does
feel strange i was just like okay i
thought each season had its own unique
flavor to do its own unique thing
and now things are hanging around and if
things are hanging around
doesn't that take up space and memory
and isn't that going against what you
kind of said
i don't know maybe it doesn't maybe it
does i don't know at this point we're
not probably going to be getting new
planets
we're not getting new areas for like the
seasonal content
they're gonna get what's there so let me
read this real quick and then we'll talk
um okay let's get it here's a look at
what's sticking around from season to
hunt
until the end of year four so until we
get which queen
whatever date that falls again we can
speculate that on the end story missions
will be
able to be launched from a node in the
director
that's going to look different but
staying around
that is a good thing yes people who
didn't get to experience
like the saint missions are the key ones
i always go back to
the people who miss those like missed a
huge like it's tragic that they didn't
get to see those
running through the corridors of time
going to save him
seeing like the the implications of the
dawn season for
what people missed story was was big so
good it was so good the story was just
so good was saying now on the complete
reverse rathborn hunts are staying
around
i don't know if anybody would care if
they left or not
they're like they're so quick and short
so quick
they're so like i mean people are like
yeah you can knock them out in like
three minutes
mm-hmm two and a half with lament
something like like i mean people just
smash these things
uh the adored quest will continue to be
available so you're what are these
things called now pursuit weapons is
that right
i don't even know if that is that what
they're called i'm trying to remember
anyway which color rag you gonna get for
which activity weapon
yeah the scarf weapons will be things
oh i've got the orange because i did all
these shots in vanguard
that's that's what mine would be because
it was just easy to knock it out yeah
screen on tangled shore will stay
that's a whole piece we'll get to in a
second exotic quest and master activity
now those are gonna stay for the year
but they say till the end of year four
so again the random rolls the end of
year four that goes away somebody gets
hearing witch queen
hey what's hawkmoon in pvp well you can
only get the slightly less version
you'll never get one as good as i have
still want to see how they answer that
one yeah
the seasonal seal and warden title will
stay around so you can actually get your
seasonal seals
for longer but apparently to get the
bungee reward piece you got to do it
within the season itself
but you can kind of earn the warden
title in game a little bit longer
things that are going to go crows
bounties messages from the field i
honestly forget what those are
you guys yeah what is that i don't know
i don't it's that i don't know if it's
like voice lines or something is that
the voice line when you're in the trust
land
and the edz or is that the this is punt
stuff so it might be like
stuff related to oh maybe maybe at the
end of each joint remember when osiris
crow and
glint are talking at the end of each
hunt when you kill him
maybe something like that it's got to be
something like that that's probably all
yeah so like yo you guys do yeah
um they said sheeping sheep shaping
words shifting to keep more of this
content around after the season ended
has created some weirdness for the
season to hunt and this is one where
they kind of cover
our weird issue with crow which was
initially designed during the older
models and this is the whole things are
on about a six-month cadence so just
kind of remember that
this is why crow has still is still
hanging around in spider's lair right
after being unceremoniously kicked out
after the end of the season
they listen to
you may see other anomalies involving
crow in season 13 as he'll be moving to
a new destination
while also remaining in the tangled
chore somebody in chat earlier said his
brother
is gonna be in the tangled shore his
evil twins hanging out over there is the
vendor screen
but he's not gonna have bounties so you
can just unlock the lure but he doesn't
have bounties anymore over there
but it's it's like so that one's weird
but they say after season 13
or for season 13 and onward it's been
designed with the new system
so that stuff does has been designed to
remain in the game and i guess this is
like how they're telling their stories
this year feels like zeva wrath is going
to be kind of what leads into sabathune
and all that stuff gdo's starting a bit
early
easy killer we'll get to that
um and i may knock these out here in a
minute just to get you guys going but
the idea here is
obviously with season of the hunt the
crow kind of got a cool interaction
it unfortunately breaks the story when
you walk him out of there and he's like
hold on i forgot something
and then he sits back down and he hangs
out again there's an issue with him
still being in there and my head
breaks the story it kind of starts
completely they know in season 13 he's
going to move
now granted if you can like you know
have the suspend disbelief like yeah i
know he's kind of broken over there but
just leave him alone
he's gonna have his new spot in 13. so
he is going to move which is promising i
wish
that would have been like in the last
week you walk him out he may have need
to pack up his stuff and then he's go
find a new place like
a shorter hang around time to move yeah
but yeah it's like now in season 13 14
and 15
this stuff is designed to stay around so
like whatever they have in there
is stuff they they see as a story beat
for us to continually do or we can have
like
a lot of people are wondering about
cabal rathborn hunts because you have
the scene with osiris zavala
those two haven't talked in ages yeah
plus two cabal
champion guys sitting there next to him
as well looking at some holographic
projection
like i don't know what story is going to
bring those four people into the same
room
yeah like that seems crazy but the idea
is like
now instead of like here's done as this
little encompassed little package and
then
next one and then here's your next
little bucket chunk that away like
worthy okay raspbian belch none of
that's here
here's the next stuff for rivals that
tied in it feels like this year is a
rivals that's leading into something
right so i was kind of curious while i
go knock out my sit-ups
and the push-ups you guys suck
while i go do that you guys discuss so
you have to get
a rocket let me cloud a rocket as evil
take care of business for them
put a campfire let's go eat cookies
listen man the chef got to work
sometimes man gotta get right
let's go let's go chef
let's get it you see you don't get you
don't get this in you okay
we don't say it in the park
[Laughter]
what do you think clown what you think
with this whole thing bro um
i don't know again i think it's a really
strange movement i think they've
they've put a bit of a again a bit of a
lackluster into it i think with the
whole crow being in two different places
there was no need for that there is
there is no need for that like put a
panel up on the screen in in spider's
lair like put a computer there sticker
yeah
weird freaking oh you could have put
absolutely anything there as far as him
being
like i've got a clip because i did the
uh
i did that part on on stream where
we had we took him out of the spider's
lair i'd gone back in
i'd gone to i was like just stood there
just looked at him didn't move didn't
say a word my stream was completely
silent for about three seconds and i
just pushed my chair back and i was like
i have just taken you
the hell out of here he said i could
take anything i could have probably a
big ass throne
yeah i could have taken that chair and
hauled that throne out of that lair
i took your ass out and you're standing
there
i'm gonna volunteer
[Music]
it is cool to see at least they finally
explained
technically what the issue was in the
12th that it happened because they
they themselves admit that looks stupid
yeah 100 percent so i think they're the
ones in the game yeah
one thing that i i'm really really i say
proud like a
bloody father but one thing i'm proud of
bungie with of recent
is they're acknowledging the actual
issues so yeah they are issues and yeah
we can all talk about them until we're
blue in the face
but when you see those tweets so they're
like yeah okay
this is this this is this we're gonna
post this up and we know this is a
problem
and we've only had three weeks since you
guys started hammering videos down our
throats
right now we're gonna process the moon's
stuff and the
um the dream and city stuff right but
hopefully come the next season they've
obviously pushed through this
and the other so they're acknowledging
it and i think that's one thing which is
really really good
that they don't normally do well i agree
i think that that's why
it's matt like i know everybody's bad
you know and i get it you know
rightfully so there's things that need
to be corrected
you know for me i can't get
i can't go crazy on someone who
like you said at least is transparent
with me
with their issue and the thing i'm mad
about
right now do they slip and make some
similar mistakes often yeah
and those things should be corrected we
shouldn't repeat
mistakes but if this person wasn't being
honest with me and saying yo now you
know what
we got to fix that that's not it you
guys are not feeling that
and that's why that's why i guess for
the people who don't understand why we
love destiny this is the reason why i
stick in because there are those times
where you're like damn what are they
doing
and then when they hit and they hit
right it's like
the best thing in the world right
there's nothing beating it at that point
so that's i think that's just where it
is you know so again i need
me personally needed to see that
paragraph about crow
because it it made no sense we ripped
them to shreds the last
last word you know what i'm saying and
to see them say nah this is a system
this is a systemic change that when we
go into this new format
you won't see this type of thing again
because this is working on the old
system
crow's working on the old format of
transitional content kind of thing
so you know that's where i'm at with it
i mean i don't know where he's at after
his fantastic workout today
i was like catching my breath a little
bit now just let you rock
so yeah i was like from what you guys
said it is good that they acknowledged
it because we're
sitting here like dude stockholm center
like what is wrong with you get out of
here
leave and then they're like he's going
to give it a minute that's fine
um i am wondering when they talk about
like the ever-evolving world
obviously they plan this stuff to be a
little bit more in the future which will
help the
less you know story breaking pieces of
like crow sitting around in the tower so
i'm honestly glad that like that's a
good thing because
that's what we're going for we want to
see this stuff they want to see the
world evolve you want to have
you know this interaction with osiris
zavala and two cabal guys from whatever
scent we want that to actually like
that's going to be a huge moment we want
to see how that affects the story and
relationships and like
you know all these pieces so i'm very
curious to see what they do
and i'm honestly curious how it changes
the story because we got
we got cool stories with like dawn and
the story with worthy fell winter that
the
ships like that stuff actually was kind
of cool i really enjoyed how those are
done
right uh some of that stuff would work
like the ships on the wall coming in
during the season that led to arrivals
perfectly
like that connection kind of came in but
on the other side
you have stuff like done and the
quarters of time bailed so i am liking
the idea that if something stays around
it's going to be there for a while but
as i said before
when you get to 15 how does that change
is it's like
this is going to be in for three months
and then you're still gonna like lose it
as opposed to things so not everything
has the same length of life i guess is
what the weird thing is now
as well as seasons of seasons of season
three months period you're good
as opposed to now it's like one's got 12
nine six three months
yeah how are those gonna feel as you go
into like season 50 and we're like hey
if you haven't jumped into destiny a
while now's the good time to do it we
also just discussed the cost stuff
earlier
if somebody jumps into 15 do they also
have to buy like three other 10
things more than the discounted
expansion probably is right
at that point to experience like now
they could catch up on the story which
is good
they could be like all right this is the
crow here's the hunts then go do this
then go do this
and they can actually see it all which
is fantastic i love that that stuff will
stay around
there's just some weird logistical stuff
that i'm curious how they handle because
story like experiences staying around
for a whole year
makes sense the whole vaulting stuff
for other games i know that's their
choice and hey it's done it's gonna
happen period but
it is still weird to be like hey by the
way you still can't go see how saint 14
got in the tower we could have because
we were there but
you missed it like yeah it still kind of
sucks that some of that stuff's gone but
it is done and gone but i like at least
the year will work better so we'll just
have to see how it goes i don't know
mine's more just like the more i think
about it the more logistics like explode
my head so i'm just gonna have to watch
and see how it happens
i'm gonna break yeah we gotta see i'm
with you especially
with the new light player how does that
work for him
right that how does he experience any of
these things
you know is it behind the paywall so i'm
with you on the logistics of the new
player especially
yep i can't imagine him making him pay
out for all the seasons friday
so like the previous three two three
seasons beforehand or whatever
i can't imagine them make it like paying
the extra pieces to get that extra
content in i'd be really surprised
yeah i think i'd be disappointed because
we've still got a lot of new light
players coming in through the cracks now
man
a lot of them in the comments section
i'm like dude
like yeah there's so many what made me
alter my content because i was just like
beforehand i was just like following
like the movement of the game and i was
like hold the phone no no no
like there are things that these people
need to know that i've just jumped in
now so my comment section sometimes
there's people going dude this is
covered blah blah and i'm like yeah i
know
i get that but we'll upload a video for
you elite players tomorrow
we're focusing on the the little man
that's only just
gone and bought destiny and decided to
jump in and he wants to learn how to do
this hundred percent
that's what i'm trying to tell people
you're on fire club players like
again i know my hardcore guys i know a
lot of you guys are pissed i see the
content creative videos i'm quitting i'm
quitting i get it
but that's not the real life climate the
real life climate is people are coming
to this game and drill
just for 60 frames per second on console
alone yeah
people are like yo i just fired up
cognito
yo i want to play destiny with you and
i'm like okay
you know like and they hit me up and i'm
like all right and people i'm
forte if he's in there he's seeing me in
party chats
and it's like college courses i'm like
okay
tell me how much uh you know materials
you have okay you're low on this here
there's this guy named the spider
you log into him every day you go see
what the materials are if you're low on
you do the exchange rate
oh you see this guy banshee because a
lot of guys don't even have
um all those regular standard mods
there are so many mods that people do
not have and they have an rng
and that's a weird thing again like the
only way to get them is this like
what's he selling today yeah what's he
say like what's the rng
role and that's again that's another
system that he's looked at for players
it's like
your basic scavengers and other stuff
those need to be
those there needs to be some place for
you to like grind those out go earn them
do about i don't care
like the older stuff that we all have
had for a while
mm-hmm the whole buying mod components
for it that's right
like no that needs to be small
i'm kind of like dude some of the people
i play with are struggling for those
mods they're like
right okay let's just put on let's put
on the scavengers let's put on that ammo
finder said like i don't have that clown
i don't have okay
what is this it's cool you can make this
work but
they need to make that accessible man
like especially like the older mods
oh yeah absolutely bro i'm telling
people they didn't even know
they're losing their mind off of lament
and stuff
and i'm like bro you don't even have
loose and blade yet
like you don't even there's things like
you think it's powerful now
wait do you you know and they have no i
people don't even have
a protective light they don't know what
charged with light mods do they don't
know
any of this stuff and then it's like
each day a little bit more it's like
college
i give them course one on the basics
then you know of course two is this the
ghost story is mine and they come and
then
they get addicted and then now they're
tuning in every day like oh what's going
on
that was like hey i want to i want to
rain with you i'm like slow down but
like slow down kid you know say where's
your light ain't my man back for destiny
shot for back for dead i am a podcast
clan this guy is
our champion sherpa like he takes
people through deep stone crypt like no
others but he's got
everybody in the clan with clears i love
this guy he's so expensive man
yeah and it's like we sit there and it's
just so
fun to do it so again i know the
hardcore but
the car call community's mad but really
people are
flocking to this game in droves whether
it be the game pass the 60 frame
whatever it is on console
they're flocking and i think that's what
people have to understand so
they just got to do both they got to
still recognize us at that time to
embrace it if we're going to expand this
community and grow it from the bottom to
the top again
then you've got to embrace the small
people too like it's just
yeah well that's something bungie needs
to do too is like
you have i mean it was it's
just odd decisions that they try and
make a new light experience where you
sit on the cosmo
or yeah cosmodrome for a little while
but then you're like hey if you
want to go buy the forsaken campaign
you're going to see one story mission
cade's gonna
not have a great day they're not gonna
have a reference as to why
right and it's like again like this
there's things
and again there should be a vendor there
should be some kiosk
something for like the basic mods your
scavengers your reserves like if they
have access to nearly all of those with
just some time and effort like
hey you can go do these currencies hey
here's a bounty go do this scavenger you
want machine gun scavenger go get some
machine gun kills like
find some pretty easy way for them to
get the base level stuff and then charge
with
charged with light there should be a
quest line to explain that one like war
mine cells
if they keep them around in the game or
if they're gonna sunset them which we're
going to see another question yeah we
got to see how that's going to work
that's a big deal
because yeah the charge with light seems
a little more permanent because it's
just based on
orbs that's not as big of a deal because
that's something we've always done
but sun setting war mine cells
theoretically are they just like
is every six months are we gonna get
some arrivals weapons or some
serious weapons and they're just gonna
throw a few more back at us with
sunsetting which after a while it's
gonna feel bad
be like okay here's your seven serif
revolver
so we can keep the mods relevant it's
like
i was like somehow again that stuff kind
of gets to be a little frustrating too
so but as you said cog there's people
who don't know it exists
and there's zero in the game there's
zero things in the game that takes them
to
charge with light mods there was uh one
of the war mine cells that came up it
was like
i tweeted about it the other day and it
was it came through
and somebody would see that and be like
the hell is this like
there is zero explanation to that and
there's zero reason for them to be like
i need to go understand charge there's
nothing that explains that
in the game period and i'm like so it's
not a dark souls game where people need
to try and figure this out
stuff out on their own and like
experiment that's not the goal like
some of that stuff needs to be put in
there more obvious and the base mod a
lot of the mods need to be made more
accessible
yeah they make it a lot easier for all
of us as well i posted up a video not
long ago about the ikelos smg
a lot of my subscribers were just like
dude we have had this for so damn long
and i'm like human
i get that like the only reason i put
that video up was because like some of
the people i was talking to was just
like dude what the hell is that
like how how does that work how do the
mods work on on warming sales because
some people still don't know how it
works like
and it's not always the easiest thing to
kind of learn
while you're trying to go through a game
like destiny right
so it's difficult i think people just
need to go into this game with an
open mind and take everything with a
pinch of salt and just kind of
go through the parts that are relevant
to you no
absolutely absolutely i mean you made a
fantastic point the fact that you're
doing that
is pretty cool cloud because um you know
i was gonna ask you like how how are
those
videos and stuff kind of doing for you
or that content is doing
for you uh not not overly amazing i
can't like
it doesn't do like amazing but if i post
a video up and it gets 3 000 views
if that helps 10 people it helps 10
people yeah you know i mean so
as long as i can keep the balance from
doing things which are classified as
newbie videos but then going in
and doing that right okay this is how
you glitch into this part and do this
and go and collect this
for the more elitists then and so be it
you know i mean
you're not always going to be liked by
everybody so why not try and cover more
ground
fair enough and uh yeah yeah shout out
they said why not let new players
do like players pull the mods from
collections if they have the currency
option and then um also yeah just give
more sources man give more sources
besides just two you know measly mods
for people who
don't have anything you know what i'm
saying or the people that are trying to
get like the one like a random rng
just to try and get your lucid blades or
your protective light
doesn't feel great like there's enough
rng in this game but a mod that changes
the way your build works you need to
there needs to be some type of path even
for the people who've been playing for a
while and like
slept for a day or two oh i missed it
like who knows oh yeah
so we've got a vendor and a collections
point for near enough
everything else throw that in there too
well get to the hot one more things
coming back
umbrellas this is not is this the hot
one i was like the next one's the hot
one
haha instagrams are
back if you guys were here in season of
rivals obviously it's the engrams you
can then focus it into something
um they're gonna be bringing these back
they're gonna function
slightly different they're gonna not
come for they'll still look like they're
coming from a lot of stuff
patrol strikes crucible gambit
nightfalls public events blind well
nightmare hunts two things which i still
forget exist half the time
exo challenges empire hunts and new
seasonal activity
they're not gonna drop in raids it looks
like or dungeons but everything else
they're basically
that's true that's true so they are
going to lower the drop rate from
season of arrivals because they we were
swimming in these things
probably okay with but also get rid of
my blues and my postmaster's not much of
an issue so you know still any men
get to the source get to the source of
the problem
we don't need to lower the drop rate of
umbrals if there's
blues aren't exposing everywhere but
yeah like but lowering them now i mean
we were literally swimming in these
things so it's fine um
and then also comes back the prismatic
recaster to function with those
now first question the picture of the
prismatic recaster
we talked about it last night so i don't
want to say anything first where do you
guys think this thing is
cloud i reckon we're gonna reopen up ada
one's room
hey i think i think we're aiming down
that route i think that's a very viable
place for a hundred percent
like had the the one and only jarvinius
in chat chat last night while we were
talking about this and he said the same
thing
like i mean everybody i saw that
floating on twitter i'm like the
flooring even looks like that so
somehow wherever this thing is placed
feels like we're going to be
going back in there so any lower
implications
any um why we're going in there i don't
know like
okay but i also was like well what the
hell happened to aydah
do you guys actually know what happened
to her nope
so thanks to a lord oh god now i've got
to go find it
crystal you're in here lol meister
somebody in chat remind basically 801
has this like um she has kind of this
like epiphany thing
she's like i know the darkness is here
and i also know what i'm capable of
doing and she has she's very torn as an
exo she's like
i can share this knowledge with all
other exos and make us more powerful
and then i could also make um basically
exo's more powerful
i can help us fight the darkness but in
turn i also have this very specific
knowledge of you know the black armory
weapons and all of the stuff that she
can create
so she's trying to decide like does she
want to go to
i think somebody said she's either going
to europa trying to decide if she wants
to
go work with clovis and the exos and the
deep stone crypt and all that stuff
to figure out if she wants to basically
help us with all the knowledge or still
be a vendor
but she's kind of in this weird kind of
conundrum of she's got a lot of
knowledge that she knows can help us
build weapons
but then if everybody has the knowledge
she's like well then you guys are just
another faction of actuals and not
special
so she's kind of in the background
working on something
or trying to decide so she's got more
stuff that she wants to do
and i wish i didn't have to go find that
it is on the hunter
helmet okay from the jeep stone crypt
armor that's the only place this lore is
the hunter helmet lore from the deep
stone crypt armor and somebody's like
look it up
and i read it and i was like damn why
did i not know this before
that happens a lot though oh god yeah
shout out to this i
still don't know why osiris is in the
tower right oh yeah
i mean i need to know at some point too
i mean we got a tren they're definitely
setting something up
you know but as far as him um you know
with the seguira's death
at least at least with the um what was
the mission with the high celebrant
yeah i got some mention of the fact that
cigarette
you know said i was like thank you for
that you know and avenging and
you got some emotion behind it but um
yeah they're definitely setting them up
because uh
what was it the again the bungie
um you know article the lore
article you know saying where they had
the meeting
with between aikora you know
zavala you know and mention not osiris
in the reinstatement
and then i they're definitely setting
something the vibe i'm getting is he's
going to be
an advisor you know almost two savala
a lot of the um tower measures obviously
we saw with crow
he told the guardian look don't tell
anybody about crow just yet
we know how his history or who he was
you know could be very
explosive part of king but we will
reveal the vibe i'm getting from him
he's going to be this is my guess this
is going to be the mediator in the tower
yeah he he the mediator this the vibe
i'm getting from him
he's gonna not it remember he's with
mortality he's got to stay in the towel
you know saying
you know ghosts you got to say todd you
ain't running around outside like that
but the vibe i'm getting is he's going
to be
the advisor that's going to push zavala
to do
unconventional things that he's not
always comfortable with because zavala
is that
by the book play it by the light all
right guardians you're finished with
that darkness right
we're going to ban that that's over with
no you know
so osiris is that he's the gray line
because osiris will push things
to get to an end and i think that's what
the vanguard need you know so he doesn't
want to really be a vanguard
but he's going to do what it takes to
get things done i see
that's the role they're evolving the
character is that's my guess i think i'm
pretty strong
we'll see that's that's my guy i think i
think that's and that's why
he's taking up residence there because i
think next season
whatever whenever that cabal cinema that
we still haven't seen right seriously
he's going to be permanent resonating
he's going to be like mini speaker 2.0
influence
in the timeline that's going to find a
white mask
keep that fraudulent
we don't do the white bass over here we
got our faces out
but that's just me that's what i think
it's gonna go but it's gonna be
interesting i'm curious to see
what's going on mm-hmm shout out i'll
say it's hilarious continue
but yeah so basically they're bringing
back the idea to focus
engrams to i mean they said they're
going to have pages in the prismatic
recaster for different seasons
and then just as before now the question
is the prismatic lens and this is where
i was talking about currencies
right earlier and how they balance
things because they say we have a new
way to unlock different focusing options
for your umbral engrams through a
different reward called prismatic lenses
prison bat prismatic lens will unlock a
new focusing option
so you can target a narrower collection
of gear
target specific armor stats similar to
we had before you had like groups of
weapons
from different times and eras and then
armor for like
higher intellect or higher whatever
you'll be able to earn prismatic lenses
by doing various activities in the game
and you can track your progress towards
unlocking lenses at the prismatic
recaster
we don't want to spoil everything though
so let you discover how you start
earning these in season 13.
my only worry and i'm just going to say
it first
like many things the
rathborn lure for example is a prime
piece like this
when they're like hey here's this thing
we want you to grind for
oh we've made this grind monotonously
long and too slow
now we're going to be able to get them a
little bit faster here's a little bit
more
readily available lenses oh these come
faster too the grind's not quite as long
you can hold more of them that's what
it's going to be like at the end of
season 13 at the beginning we're going
to be like i got one and it's been two
weeks
is how it's how i have a hunch this is
gonna go
that may not be that extreme but i was
like it's cool to let go after the focus
in the umbrals but
don't make the lit cause there's enough
rng in the game already
like hey i narrowed it down to two
weapons cool i want a cold denial
and there's the other thing i don't care
about okay i hit that one how many roles
do i have to go after that i only get 50
and then i go in the stats but i can
only narrow it down with these lenses as
well
like i'm just hoping they don't make
this too hard to come by
i know they want rng to be there but um
so i know there's you know as you say
daddy bungee saying like don't can't go
can't get too direct of a path
you already have enough rng is all i'm
saying so it doesn't have to be
that hard to get all i'm saying
so thoughts i feel you
if they can be a little hard on them but
i'll jump in
listen i like umbrellas i love dumb
rules if it wasn't for umbrals i
wouldn't have my
last in was it first in last out with
the god roll that i used for deep stone
[ __ ]
because i was just focusing all day
towards the end of the season and just
cashing them joints in
until i got specific roles um i think
that's a good thing
you know as far as the lens i understand
where you're going though i mean yeah
it's an extra
layer right off so to speak you know of
but to me it's more focused targeting
right
so doesn't the um let me ask you this
doesn't the umbrella provide
some choice in roles and paths
or no depends on how they handle it you
know rivals like
you would get an umbrella and you could
go to like a bigger
group but not like the world loot pool
of like 30 or 40 things you could
and then you could start narrowing down
from like four or six or eight down to
like
twos or armor so you could go more but
again it depends on how they break this
apart if it's just like
seasonal stuff and then others i just
don't know
like how far because if you have like a
group of eight things you're like yeah
if you have a group of two or one it's
obviously more focused
but i don't know how they're gonna
handle those i mean for me
i'm always going to welcome focusing
because there's still weapons
i still haven't got roles i want you
know i'm saying
and one particularly is um the europa
stuff i love high albedo the the
the what is it the uh spider sidearm
that's in the kinetic spot
i want one with wellspring i cannot get
i do the damn thing
every week i pick up the stupid bounty
kill 30 things and run around patrols
and then do the empire hunt and they
give me a trash i'll be the rule
every time like i'm like can i just get
one with wellspring that's all i want
that i haven't gotten i haven't gotten
the gal roll on what is it the blast
between the one that's the
the grenade launcher that comes i want i
got chain reaction
with the spike but i want the clown
cartridge didn't get that
i want corset it's still like four guns
that i
farm all the time and i just don't get
the rolls and even with
um wrath hunts that it's better they got
the two perks you can expend
you know you can exclude and then you
got the other joints but
i just haven't been you know lucky with
that so
for me if you give me an extra layer to
focus deeper if that's what this
is i'm for it you know what i'm saying
because especially with the older guns
that i still haven't gotten god rolls
from
and you know newer guns going to come
that we're probably not going to have
that issue so i don't know
i'm i'm willing maybe i'm too optimistic
i'm willing to
to to give it a shot and i'm always
about
target focused you know rng kind of
stuff but where yeah cloud
with this whole thing um i'm fully for
it man i think as long as they slow down
how quickly we get the umbrellas i'm
right i'm more than
happy with it i think i think that
towards the end of last season
i i wanted that first and last out i
wasn't
really much of a slug shot any sort of
guy before that point but i was like
going into this next season i was like
right i need to i need to grind for that
get those umbrellas and i was i was
really happy that they were giving me so
many so quickly back then
i think if they slow it down a little
bit and then i think it can only bring a
positive spin
and i think it doesn't matter when you
come into the game at that point
that you can still pick up some decent
weapons focus it to the way that you
want to play it
and i don't really see a negative as
long as it's not
as long as the lenses work as an
additional point right right
i think it would it would work really
well if you get take your umbrella gram
and you put it into the recaster and you
can still focus it to a degree
and you get like two lenses three lenses
a week or a one lens a week or whatever
um i don't think that would phase me too
much i think that that just gives you
more opportunity to focus longevity
rather than bashing everything out at
the beginning and going at the end of
the season
we've got nothing to do right facts now
i got one caveat
they better not do it like um
exotic ciphers or something where it's
like oh you could only hold
two you know like they better not pull
that then i'm going to be upset now look
at that
yeah like that that would be crazy shout
out to back from they said i
was fun you could farm for rolls of deep
stone crap yeah i'm about to do the same
thing like
i i'm gonna be on like i'm the guy that
likes sitting in front
with the umbrellas and it's like going
to vegas going to the slot machines
i like that i'll be like alright cool
let me get up i need this this one
like i'm the guy that likes to get every
archetype with the type of role i want
it's fun to me you know what i'm saying
so all last season
i was rocking out man like i said if it
was i got that
god roll you know first and last out
with the with the precision shoddy
portable autoloading holster you know
what i'm saying i don't have no
recombination gun yet but this that's my
version
you know what i'm saying and i'm rocking
and rolling man so i love this stuff
especially with past content that you
may have been unlucky with so we'll give
it a shot
just hopefully they'll do nothing stupid
final one titles
and i had a celebrity jeopardy moment
where i almost said something else the
first time i read this but
titles
one could imagine when you've been
placed
one of the most satisfying feelings in
destiny is watching your list of
completed triumphs philip to unlock
new seals and titles so the big thing
that's happening is a lot of people
[Music]
had stuff like flawless and conquer
they've been earning over and over and
over
and they're just re-earning the same
title so they said they want they want
to allow players to show off their
engagement
with the core rituals over season over
season preserve the value of
earning the base title and decrease the
amount of grind required season overseas
for players who want to earn them all so
if you want to earn it one time you're
gonna have to go through probably the
most arduous journey
of it later on in the future you can
still earn it but you've
you know you've been down the hard part
but if you want to get it again
then you got you got some stuff to do
not all of it
so what they're working on um starting
with season 13
if a player has completed the seal for
one of the core ritual titles
unbroken for pvp crucible dredging for
gambit
flawless obviously trials conquer for
grandmaster nightfalls
players will have a series of additional
seasonal objectives to guild
that title but what does gilded mean a
series of seasonal objectives to guild a
core ritual title
a new border around the seal of the
triumph ui
a new pip tracking how many times you're
in your career that you've gilded the
title
excuse me a new color and symbol for the
title over your head so that you can
show off of course
once you finish the base seal claim your
hard earned title a list of optional
seasonal objectives will be revealed by
completing these seasonal objectives
you'll earn your guild for the season
what happens when the season is over
this is the big controversial part
each season the optional gilding
objectives will reset
and may even change to fit the unique
experiences of any given season
all of the base objectives of the title
will be preserved and your title will
revert to its typical purple coloring
this is again for the four we just
discussed
so thoughts before i say anything
so without saying that at the end of
each season all of the work that you've
done to
essentially upgrade that is going to
reset
at the beginning of the next season yeah
i'm still in my point yeah
what um so the only thing
my understanding that will say is the
little pip and basically if you guys
bring up the image which i can't do on
the podcast because there's audio
there's like a little kind of diamond
shaped little like
dot above to show how many times that
might stay
but the color of the title over your
head the look of the emblem with the
outline a little like
kind of a little more ornate nature of
it that will go away to where it always
looks each season
then what is the point
this is i i mean tell me if i'm wrong
but the number one thing
that a destiny player enjoys is showing
off their stuff man
they enjoy pushing out like look at me
i'm i'm the dogs danglies
look at this color right here only from
clown players where we go
oh my god that's a lie dangly let's go
do you know what i mean though i think
that like that was the whole idea in d1
with the nightfall when you'd get that
little glowing aura around your head
it was a hard piece of content look at
me i've done that every single day
i'm gonna get back into another season
and go great i gotta grind my color
again
like did that feel it
i'm not feeling that i like the idea of
where it is it's the reset
i like the idea of it because i can
imagine some specific people in the
community
yeah like do you know what i mean i had
tarik and
skyrim and all of them are really
hammering in and like just looking at
them going
i'm just going to stand back here
because exactly
like that's what it's there for i think
that's what
i don't understand the reset i can't but
it doesn't process
yeah yeah i mean you know one would hope
that it would just
at least even if you lost the color like
you you keep the number you don't say
like
so sit in trials reissue let's go
amazing yeah
i was curious how you were going to take
this one
cloud just said everything i needed to
say brother i just
i don't i don't get it you know the
thought
the thought process is nice right reward
the hardcore the hardcore
loves this stuff shout out to my boy
sinister shout out to all my hardcore
guys in the clan like they love
the floss in your face this unique
emblem or this unique ship or
title that they got it feels good it's
bragging rights you're that committed
but then to reset it at the end of the
sudden you go right back down to a
regular old dredging or
write down a regular unbroken and it's
like you know
why you know kind of thing so gilded in
theory
sounds cool i like that they're saying
this from
each season i guess it will change what
specific requirements to get like
some objectives will somehow change
between seasons
some may be the same yeah
i mean i think that's fine like i i like
that part i think the idea of giving
something else to chase is is definitely
something that we will take in the
destiny community but i think that right
why would you reset it where's the
launch here's my thing what about what
about some damn rewards though
what about the title and some rewards
for this like that's where i'm at like
where's the hot
ship gun ornament something that okay
you did this oh you can't get this
unless you do this
you know what i'm saying like that's my
thing like this this is cool
all right that's cute you got your
little name in life
yeah it's just a word like where's the
like
flashing like like kyle said like
remember we did knight falls in d1
you want some spectacular i want a damn
strobe like i want the heavens parting
i want the red sea i want flower petals
when i come in the tower
that's what i want you know i want you
to feel nice when you walk down to
yes i want to feel majestic i want to
feel loved
that i did this where are your trials
ornament wings
hey where's that egyptian almond rye
stuff
dominant out here and i can't do that so
hundred percent
you don't go into the tower and look at
people and go damn he looks cool do you
know how much time i spent in the tower
in destiny one
looking at those radars before i got my
hands on them
it's just you know again right idea
just the execution stop yes
it's just it's the people are gonna be
like okay as soon as that reset you know
it's gonna be like okay you know it's
almost my remember we had this issue
with um
the grand master nightfall okay more
material oh okay
you know it's like they imagine they
look on people's faces when they grind
for it for ages they don't know that it
resets at the end of the season
they roll into the next season and that
reverse oh
they're gonna do it once and be like
what the where'd it go
and then they're gonna see that little
like dot and be like i'm sorry that's
all i got
yeah like some like maybe you could put
a cap on the number of times you do this
and maybe after like
six there's not like a change or
something but you could go like
you could have the gold outlined then
you'd go like gold and like silver
and then you can change there's so many
like cosmetic
like little sections of these things
where you can start like
throw some like rubies or diamonds or
germinates and i'm like yeah gemstones
like
go go a little crazier with this stuff
and then for the title as well like you
could do colors you could do like a
little flare you could do like
like give that little text floating
above above somebody's head
a lot going on if they've done it like
three times already and then four
five six like have that be seen and then
if somebody's like hey here's this like
the seal i got for the sixth time and it
looks just like this glorious ornate
wreath crazy bananas looking you know
royalty
piece of just like go nuts like that's
the type of stuff if somebody
the type of people who want to do this
want that type of thing
by actually but you know where they do
you know what they do go nuts at
the day of eververse
nuts it's all that you talk about him
every verse
but for the game in the game we get
red font 2 or so they could convert that
so well like even if they wanted to do
the reset each season
like there's some other games out there
i can't even remember which ones
to be fair but they could convert that
into an emblem or a class item or
something that's cosmetic
but it doesn't change your state of the
game so you can i could grow for that
batch
get that badge and at the end of the
season they go right okay well that
badge is resetting and
next season will have a whole bunch of
different badges here's an emblem to
commemorate why you got up to
yes great or like here's an ornament
which has got like i don't know a cloak
with a
really emblem on the back of it or
something like give something that's
going to last
other than a memory in a photo
i agree i agree i mean it
and that's quite easily done yeah these
these are just easy fixes right claire
like these are
easy fixes and it just why is it a
struggle why is this such a
disconnect at least listen you're
telling people to go flawless
unconqueror unbroken you're telling
people to do
dredging again like these are not easy
activities like
you mean you for the most part it's a
time commitment and skill you have to
put in work so i'm just like
yo like you got to do better you got to
do better with time investment and
reward
this i cannot the heart's in the right
place
the execution is just not there
not there yeah that's what i mean that's
you take the people who want to do this
they should have something pretty pretty
awesome to show can you imagine
if like they gave you a
single ornament piece per time you
gilded this thing
because you're going to transmog with
ornaments coming up and it would take
you five seasons to get this just
magical set of ornaments and you're like
max
five seasons do this you're telling me
people wouldn't go for this stuff just
looked absolutely bananas bonkers like
age of triumph crazy freaks like age of
triumph triumphant
d1 iron banner when you had the flame
stuff and the thing you know go bonkers
bro
we love this stuff remember what was it
legacy the
when they brought the old raise back d1
and you did um whatever
you got the wi-fi symbol and the thing
and like you were looking great like
what is this
why is why is the art team
and the ornament team only selectively
good
in eververse like why is eververse the
only thing that's
popping when it comes to these creative
ideas but in the game
we get the green red and blue remix
drapery gambit you know or
arm like we get trash stuff that doesn't
even compare and i'm just like come on
y'all
come yeah the dawning armor set wear
something like that in game
the ornate nature of the dotting now i
will say like the deep stone [ __ ] stuff
kind of looks cool
no deep stone [ __ ] i gotta give them
that i was like that one looks kind of
cool
but i still think like the the ornate
nature of the dawning donning
is more is more flair than you'll ever
see
like but the glows and stuff like that
and they have the power now with all
these systems and everything it's like
we're not dealing with
a ps3 so yeah i don't know yeah that was
just
i read that and then saw like the
twitter stuff people were like yeah it's
how many times are we gonna have one
step forward half step back
two steps forward one step back like
everything has like
hit it's like the reward this is
inexcusable though from a reward
standpoint
like they've got to know better than
this and i really come at them this hard
but it's just like
you got to know what is required to do
these things and
all you're doing is that come on bunji
we come on we got to do better we got to
do better
we're rewarding this base if you want
the hardcore not to be upset like they
are
these are the things that that get
people upset you know
i feel like we've been talking but what
are your thoughts anything else dad
no no no no definitely um i think that
you've literally nailed on the head i
think the one thing that i love doing is
customizing my character with
awesome armor pieces and awesome
ornaments and colorization do you know
how much time i spend playing around
with shaders it's embarrassing
yeah you guys in your dresses it's fine
can i just throw this out there
hopefully at some point
please can shaders not be consumable
just please at some point
they should not be consumables yes
it's just a weird it's just it's a weird
system yeah anyways
system but i don't think that's my
biggest worry with shaders my biggest
worry about shaders is how i put
look at a shader block that looks really
nice apply it to my character
where the hell did that purple come from
yeah
where's the hidden two other colors in
there be like
i'm gonna throw something gray purple
gold on a ship and all of a sudden it's
like yellow i'm like what
no what where is that yeah you just have
to like apply and guess
you have to but i don't i can't do that
to everything because half that crap i
don't want to hold on to it's in my
collection so it's like
i would experiment more if i could look
through every shader i would experiment
more but
there's only the ones that i have on my
character at the current time so not
faith warlocks we we
just built different probably 60 percent
every day and i've been there i'm
bashing every day if my colors don't
match i feel like i'm naked
yes i can't be out there looking crazy
man
looking like i'm dropped out of a thrift
store like exactly
well shout out to dresstilly
so that's most of the twa but there was
one more thing that happened this week
and we gotta talk about it because
so we know there are a lot of community
conversations happening around the
current state of the game
i don't i don't want to lean too far
into
quote we are listening because people
are going to lose their mind if they say
that one more time
but it's 100 true and we are taking
community feedback to heart
and are absolutely considering community
concerns suggestions as we continue to
evolve our plans for 2021 and beyond
earlier this week assistant game
director joe blackburn put out a tweet
mentioning this and will give an update
to the community
with a deeper dive into the state of
destiny and these are his words and i
want everybody's thoughts
this is the last thing for the podcast
today last year
i said destiny's best days are ahead
seeing what's coming
i believe this more than ever but we
have work to do to get there
2021 is going to be a little different
for destiny
taking some time to validate our plans
but expect a state of destiny 2021
next season
so i don't know if you've seen this yet
or you probably already processed it but
cloud
you are the guest you get honors where
where did you
where did this take you
yeah you have that many words that you
just can't i have
i have that many words i don't i don't i
don't know i don't know
if i'm completely honest with you like
my problem is is my brain just sort of
like
lapses when i read all of it i'm not
gonna lie to you like i'm just
laughing frustration or lap lapses in
uh it lapses in frustration it lapses
because i'm intrigued it lapses because
there's
like trust that they're going to change
things it lapses because
there's distrust that it's not you guys
you know i mean it
it's it's kind of my relationship with
destiny has always been a really
love-hate
relationship and it has bounced around
so much
that i'm just kind of like i don't know
i don't know what what are you guys
thinking about yeah i mean
i was surprised i was surprised because
um
i feel i'm good at the the pulse
of the field of gauging the pulse of the
community
right and this is a weird one because
like i said earlier
probably if they look at their metrics
they say hey we're
doing great you know we're in a great
spot we got all these new players i mean
outside of pvp they care there's no way
they can say that's great right
pvp it is what it is but um yeah man so
it's like
at the end go for a cloud i swear
um yeah so like at the end of the day
like for me it's like yo
they're doing well but the the most
hardcore guys are like yo i'm out
i'm not doing this you know even my man
e right here he's like yo
like not that he made a video anything
going crazy he's just saying yo the
desire to
want to you know i've done everything
right you've kind of had that i've done
everything
stage i don't know what else there is
for me you know you didn't rate as much
as i did but at the same time you got
everything out of the game you need to
do and you kind of
kind of done so when i
see this this this is what i get from it
they are listening for them to have to
come out with this tweet from blackburn
he's up there right
yeah they're listening assistant game
director so he's probably he's probably
right under yeah luke yeah he's up there
blackburn's up there so
for him to come out with this you know
and say okay that's what we've heard
that that's just because yeah seeing
when coming
he believes this morning ever it's going
to take work
2021 is going to be different so i am
curious i think they do have something
cooking that they want to get across and
they sitting on it they know our
frustration and maybe they have this
solution
but because they have they haven't been
able to intimate it to us
and we're frustrated they felt the need
to die we got to say this to let them
know
something is coming to address these
issues that's how i take it maybe i'm
being optimistic i know me and you were
going back and forth
with the dms and stuff you know they
know how the hardcore is is not happy
they got to do it they got to do
something so i think something is coming
you know they've alluded to it i'm very
curious to what it is
he's he's talking very you know
that's these best days are ahead i
believe this morning you know
that often though but honestly i don't
know if i do because
luke in the past has been like we've
heard you
like i've always felt luke's vibe was
always like yo we know we messed up here
hey we had to get away from this we did
this now we're getting on track it's
always been cool
like this is a like yo i can't wait to
this is how i get look from it he's like
yo i can't
wait to show you what we got cooking
y'all like that's the vibe i get from
it from blackburn maybe i'm misreading
it you know what i'm saying
so you know i mean i hope i hope that
that's the case
yeah like i'll pray heavily that that is
the case
but then you kind of look back through
trailers and like
i think there's a massive meme at the
moment with trials on how they reverted
in the trailer how much did they work on
training
yeah i saw that video hilarious you know
i was like
when like i was like a year ago someone
asked
else
i'm praying with both hands that they
bring
like bring the storm they bring the fire
they really come through with it and
and 2021 is kind of like that
highlighted key point for destiny 2
because i don't feel like destiny 2's
really had that yet right
i think it's had a bit of a
rollercoaster with no peak right
so i'm hoping this year it brings it
really brings it but
do you never know man i take everything
as it comes nowadays just because like
i don't i like guessing it gives that
that sort of
i don't know that mystical sort of
what's gonna happen next how's it gonna
go how the community gonna take it
right and then it just never goes away i
think it's going to go so hard
i just kind of roll man nothing i'll
finish it but i'll give it to you i mean
look
i you could very well be right they
could fall in the face they
you know we we did see the trials thing
and we only going to bring it back until
it's
you know the absolute you know and then
it died then we me and eve first read it
we saw
how they was doing the the point of
entry yeah
and we saw something we were like oh
that that's not gonna be it
so yeah i mean you're valid there cloud
not to get
too excited i hope they do i just don't
want to over hype it so that regardless
of what they bring to the table
the whole community is like well this
isn't what i was expecting
right no and rightfully so for me i've
never
seen blackburn really talk like this
i've never really
dealt with him or seen his interactions
my first time kind of so i'm going
i'm gonna hold him to his word and i'm
gonna get excited just because
you keep saying destie's best desert
that means you sitting on something that
you think is so amazing i wanna know
what you're amazing is
so i'm gonna get gas let's see let's see
because i'm gonna pull up this tweet
when things go wrong and i remember
on the 20 days you said this this was
you
and this is the game
remember a date that will live in infamy
and destiny
so i got to hold them to it you know but
either let me get i'm
dying dear this i know yeah yeah let me
get you
that soda all right so i'm gonna bring
this down line
by line by bar
here we go so first he said
last year i said destiny's best days are
ahead
seeing what's coming i believe this more
than ever now
for this line alone there's multiple
facets to
seeing what's ahead they have taken
and announced beyond light witchclean
lightfall
they have a story path they have a
narrative that they've
built and they have a general guideline
of how they're going to get from where
we are
to something hopefully awesome in the
story because they're finally at a point
where they can they've committed to
destiny 2 for three years they know the
game's going to be around a while
there's going to be a through line in
what's coming
savithoon is not that far away something
is post-sabothun is this the darkness
lightfall guardians
lightness dark that stuff the story
especially the way like i know we had
some disjointed stuff and how like
the darkness is like ours there wasn't a
big deal about it but like the 801 the
crow like
the story stuff is at a point where i
think it's
i can see that being a good thing ahead
and that's one part of destiny i will be
here for no matter what
i will i will partake in the weekly
updates i will be part of each expansion
in season
to see where the story goes and if it
ever has an end point i want to see
where it ends
that i will be here for guaranteed 100
people on the crucible side are looking
at this statement going are you
effing kidding me because they go back
to the receipts of
you know we have a renewed focus on pvp
and they're looking at their
wristwatch and going like um what are
you talking about because
we have less maps we have no less modes
we didn't even get a new map
we have less than gambit we have less
strikes and we
i know they've said for the vault that
like hey this is going to be the worst
time
we get it and paul tassie was on dcp
last night that now
with the sun setting piece which isn't
rolling too well right now and reissues
looming as always seemingly an issue for
the moment
so that reward team is built you've got
part of every season is here's what we
lose
so here's the new season of what
redacted fill in the blank you're gonna
have some new activities
these are the 20 some odd weapons that
you aren't going to be able to use in
in-game stuff anymore
that's not going to feel great um joe
blackburn
previously said in his other like
decently long article he mentioned armor
that's half your gear right and this is
one i've read it on pretty much
everywhere
to say what's up gama um gamma
like in my head i feel like there's an
armor 3.0 coming
and i've talked about this multiple
places but also in my head that feels
like it's about which queen
timing because big system changes feel
like it's that
right so the armor that i have right now
probably isn't going to change
functionally for a good while right
but also the armor i have right now is
probably going to get me to witch queen
when it's going to be good
so like i am hopeful-ish
ish for witch queen
because i think that's when bigger
system things can change
and i know they do some things in
between they'll have transmog in 14
13 we're going to have adept
grandmasters which for me just don't
i don't think they're going to do it um
all all of this is like i i'm kind of
i'm basically at the point i want to
read it before i go too up or down
because i can get hyped about stuff
that's out there i can be down in pvp
but i was like i just want to read it
word for word and i can promise you guys
on my youtube channel there's probably
going to be like an hour long video
of me going through this whole thing and
talking about it bit by bit
because it's going to be like the long
form i'm going to probably throw that on
the podcast audio because it's going to
be probably that damn long
yeah you know it's coming you know the
last part i see i hear we going i think
the last one i'll say is that
you know the key statement also is 2021
is going to be a little different for
destiny
right and to clouds i was like i'm not
even there yet so
oh sorry you want to continue you're
going to continue with yourself all i
was going to say is like
for that line specifically is because
2021 is going to be a little different
for destiny
he says taking time to validate our
plans but expect a state
those two together in my head are in the
2021 is going to be a little different
right and somebody in my chat said it
yesterday too
last year's stuff was decently into
development
or planned or otherwise pre-coded
right kova developments or delays
are gonna start hitting now even more
than they probably were
because they were working it they were
working at home now they still have to
do that so they haven't had a chance to
get back to a state of normalcy
and we did get out beyond light but we
know there's been a lot of bugs
probably more than ever we've got a feel
of that
honestly i feel like you know if you
take a sports analogy it's like
hey you know we're 2 and 12 this year
and it this is a rebuilding
this feels like the this is a transition
type
i see delays for witch queen for sure i
see that either december or
january summer i see which queen being
pushed
somewhere seasons are potentially going
to be either a little longer a little
space
and i think the things that i would like
to see
changed are big enough that the seasons
are gonna be a way to
tell stories and kind of pass time with
activities but the bigger changes if
destiny is gonna have a long life
are gonna take some time to get there
and i think the stuff that people want
like
a big ranking like take crucible like
take the glory ranking a playlist and
ladders and stuff like that that's not a
thing you do overnight
and that could have been being worked on
but depending on where that's in
development it's not going to happen
overnight
so we know that again there are things
that potentially can be done but we know
this takes time
covet makes it even farther right so i
was like i
expect biggestly i expect delays i don't
want to get my expectations too high
and he's validating plans they're
looking at like all right what does our
whiteboard for the next three years look
like let's see what we've got
and let's see what we're able to say to
kind of tell people what we have
kind of on the horizon and in plans like
we want to say hey this stuff's out in
year four cross play might be out there
hey armor 3.0 could be a thing but we
don't know when it's good like
those things may happen but it's like
mine's so far reaching
at this point it's i i i want i
really i'm gonna i can't wait to read
every single word of that because
i really i don't want to get too up or
down until i do because
we've been hopeful we've been bashing
things go up things go down we've been
surprised we've been let down and i just
don't know where to go at this point
not fair fair i mean you know again i
could see the multiple
ways people could analyze this this
statement
you know i thought the timing was
interesting you know because
again we know that hardcore ain't happy
right now you know i mean so um look i
get it you know i
but you know for me i'm with eu on the
second part
when i hear the sentence 2021 is going
to be a little different
that to me screams transition
that to me screams you know we got to do
something to get there
right um and it says taking some time to
validate our plans because the vibe i'm
getting is the plans
some more of the grand plan maybe the
curtain may come back on it and they may
let us see
what that grand plan is and then we go
oh they're gonna do that
right but in order to get there you're
gonna have to suffer with this
yeah maybe it may be one of them type
situations right
so we gotta see that but uh i'm curious
i am curious man yeah i think it's just
poking and prodding until eventually
something comes out you know i mean i i
think with with bungie
i have started to look at it on a basis
of
more like a parent and i said this to my
son recently which is hilarious
that i'm kind of using the same analogy
with a a game company
so i feel like there's so many so yeah
so many ups and downs
that like saying sorry now
oh it means nothing nothing actions
speak louder than words
so let's just start pushing this out
pressing where this goes
and see how the community reacts to it
and
i don't like i said earlier like i
understand everybody's got their own
opinions and not everybody is going to
be happy
but as long as you can keep the majority
happy
right we've still got a community there
to bounce off of
right um i think that's when it will
happen that's why i was saying like it
doesn't really get me too gassed but at
the same time
yeah i'm interested i'm just not gonna
bounce around the room
excited for big changes to come because
you need to show me that now absolutely
proof is in the pudding you got you
gotta you gotta show
like we don't i completely agree we're
all at that we've all been at that point
the talk is nice that we're listening
they even
clown themselves right we heard about
the weird listening they know
they know the temperature of the room so
again you gotta
it's that it's these are those moments
those are what i call the watershed
moments
i remember this distinctly me and you we
were doing this right before
um what was it uh go fast and all that
and
right before forsaken yeah and this is
right before the community summit right
and
and they sent everybody down there what
have you and you know it ended up
working out okay we i don't know what
this situation is i don't know
how much covid is affected i don't know
how much being on their own
without activision has truly affected
them there's so much going on that we
truly
don't know i remember at the time we
were like yo what's up whatever then we
got the explanation yo eververse play
paid for this and we got you know the um
the zero
hour because of it at some point the
curtains gonna get revealed
right the question is are people going
to be able to hold on
whatever bit of suffering that may come
you know what i'm saying
and and and and rock out you know what
i'm saying so that that's the thing and
i'm for one i'm always this is where i
will have a bungee
i'm always gonna ride with them when
they do this
only because i've been around game
industry
the games develop developers don't tell
you this much
they really don't i've seen other
communities i've seen division i've seen
anthem i've seen these games they don't
talk to them
they community like this nor bothered to
say they go and listen
so i i rather deal with the extra
controlling parent who
sometimes slips on the banana pill or
hits themselves in the face with the
ring
often but at least he's telling me oh
you know what
i'm a mess up today but i'll get it
right i'm gonna get it right
you know i'd rather deal with that
person who's least tried and talking to
me
than to deal with someone who's not i
don't know what's going on they
never talk and then the game's dead and
you're like yo what happened
right that's how i am with them so it's
up to the destiny community if if they
gonna give them
allow them this you know this chance to
make whatever it is that they got to
make right that's just where i'm at
i was like i feel like we are to
sometimes i feel like we're in a circle
we're going in a circle and we're
passing this point in the journey again
because
always we get to the bungees quiet for a
while they're doing all these things and
then they open up and then there's
transparency and then those things will
happen and then they quiet down again
and people are mad and then they open up
again because people are mad and we
gotta talk and
we go through these waves and there's
cycles of like times that are okay
and things are good and then times that
they have an impossible task
even like bouncing pvp and pve it's like
there are things that destiny
has somehow like dodged every bullet and
some people say like if
other games try to do some of the stuff
that destiny has tried
it'd be done like you may as well just
shut it down
and they have survived more than anybody
else
because of who knows what bungie's name
the looter shooter just the raids
there's so many different aspects where
somehow this thing has still continued
to survive
like despite its own errors
which is always crazy and at this point
this is
once again one of those times we're back
to a point where
i don't know what he's gonna say in
there right i was like
i i honestly you could just rattle off
600 different things that could be in
there
hey we talked about armor this could be
a thing we know transmog's coming
okay like there's so much that could be
in there
it just can't come soon enough they said
at the start of the season
they probably might let the first
seasonal activity start going
but it hopefully comes quick
maybe a month from now or so max but a
week or two into the season if they say
it now at the start of the season
maybe it's like kind of the opening
vidoc or a big article to go with it
i just i want to read those words
because until i do i mean
as somebody in chat says it's like you
know they've we've been here before but
it's like
they don't do things quickly they take a
typically a long time to get to whatever
finish line they think is good
and then by the time they get there
things may have shifted behind them and
it's always like
they're always trying to catch up to
something it seems
so yeah i don't know i was like we i
could speculate on this thing for a
while but it's like i just read it and
i'm like at this point i was like i just
want to know what's in the
words that are in there and then as
cloud said the actions that come behind
it
because they could have words there
we're going to have a renewed focus on
pvp
and then now we're at a point where like
when is this thing going to come through
it's like
those are the things that have like kind
of tarnished some of the
faith of the community that they will
deliver right
so it's like it's i don't know you go
ahead no i'm just going to say gamma
once again on fire again because he's
saying what i've been saying he said
there's a whole
then there's the whole other side of the
room viewpoint we mostly just see the
game from the hardcore community
where as they see the whole picture
including how the casual players trend
so that's it and he said so i assume a
lot of the changes are based off the
casual player base
that we just can't see and again that's
why i've been i've been preaching to my
hardcore brothers i'm like yo
bro i'm i'm sharper and like crazy i'm
i'm talking to people like craig people
are getting into destiny like they have
these metrics they
there's clearly something else going on
that the focus is there
right and and and not now the hardcore
has been definitely neglected on some on
some level
and they have to now reel it in and
balance and the last point i want to say
and i'll give it back to you cloud is
that
you know we i i'm a firm believer that
the reason why that circle that he
is talking about that cyclical pattern
that we always in with destiny
i'm a firm believer this thing is all
resource based
i i i firm believe because what we liked
it
was during the activision heyday time
and activision was kind of over them
no you're gonna get this out before call
of duty
no you're gonna do it how we say we're
gonna do it
now was it the most great relationship
was that points it was contentious
absolutely right but them on their
own to me this is my opinion they
outside of forsaken and a few
brights well even brother forsake was
under activision right yep
all year right so as of now on their own
it's almost what it's been a year how
close to a year now what has it been on
their own shadow keep was the first one
on their own
yeah maybe yeah yeah yeah shadow kick
was the first one they owned
beyond light now the second one i'm
trying to remember now yeah something
like that
on their own they have not proven to me
that they can consistently give us the
content
in the manner and the fashion that we
want right
so the way i look at it you see tension
out here throwing money around
you see microsoft out here throwing
money around you know what i'm saying
they in my opinion you know what i'm
saying they need those resources they
need that secondary that studio that
the high moon the vicarius to help the
blue remember
during that time we got season opulence
these are the opelins people really
liked it we got
the menage that was vicarious in them
right that wasn't
that for a year and a half year and a
half because they split yeah it was like
the june
big vidoc presentation thing but we
still had the season that we were like
in that was like not part of so yeah
there was that it was about a year and a
half i guess
so yeah like and when they're when
they're by themselves
now we've got a year to assess them it's
not been
they've had moments they had okay boom
okay this was cool gone to salvation
even raids got pulled back secretly
right
raids are once a year now right yeah
like everything's getting pulled back so
i look at it is yo they still
need help and i for one
wouldn't mind if preferably microsoft
backed the truck up
i don't know how i feel about 10 cent
but that's another story for another
podcast for another day
yeah and get the resources they need if
they get the resources they
need i think we help
alleviate that problem i think the
problem is
if they've got certain vision for the
game and other people's vision for the
game are always going to be different
because when it's your vision that's
your vision
and i think that the thing that makes it
difficult is
they've got five six seven different
segments to this game that they're all
trying to manage underneath one roof
like sometimes you need help man fast
and they're doing matter
they're doing the other ip that it's not
everyone knows the biggest ib they're
doing another ip
you got you need resources so how how
many
devs are really on that's that's my
biggest wonder i wish i knew the split
of destiny versus
christopher barrett's game like some
people have also said like christopher
barrett while he was there
was one of the pieces that helped to
balance
or had at least helped with the
direction of destiny
during his time and since kind of when
you haven't seen him
as much anymore taking over that helm
how many i mean they may be up to an 800
employee studio
is what do you hear they added like 25
of the employees
haven't been in the studio well if they
were 600 added a crap ton more working
from home
all this stuff's being built but even
like say a
third or more like what if it's even
half and half
you have no bonus studios and you have
less of your potential in-house
working on your game like box throw
covet on top of that
yeah and then they're covered exactly
that's why it's like the delays i think
are inevitable
for one but also it's like they've said
like forsaken's not happening again
size of forsaken isn't happening they
said that this is
the season set expectation you're right
they did say this
like and then the seasons like opulence
black armory
those things aren't happening either
like we got sundial and people who are
missing that
at this point facts so sunday's probably
the best
activities just throwing balls at the
day yeah
i just think they need help i think that
they need to pick
a partnership that works for the brand
that works for the model and the make of
the game
and that works as far as division going
forward because i feel like
destiny uh has this vision that it wants
going forward but again like you said
cog it doesn't have the resources to
fulfill what they're saying in the
trailers
exactly it just doesn't and i think
that's the bid that's really difficult
because i think they
sell the game vocally they sell the game
via their trailers which are amazing
they're marketing teams
and secondly that's insane insane but
the
problem is it's like i know they say
that in a trailer it gives all the best
bits but like
i love bungie like a hundred percent i
love
the game it's like the blood in my veins
they literally take the saying they put
the best bits in the trailer to a whole
new damn level
like they sell their best bits and then
they've not got the resources behind
them or
the other teams backing them to be able
to push through it with a second punch
mm-hmm i agree i agree and it's like
it's it
it's half-baked it's some parts that are
really strong in other parts like hey
what happened here how could this happen
you know and again i have to look at i
always judge people by the body of the
work you're good your actions are going
to tell me
what's going on and now i've had a year
to assess you on your own
it's not been the worst thing ever i'm
not going to go there you know what i'm
saying
is it's definitely not at your highest
you don't see because that's your
highest was forsaken during destiny 2 in
my opinion
so when you like he said when you come
out by yourself and then set
expectation we will never have anything
as big as forsaken anymore
you've already set expectation now right
you've already lowered it
right so it's resources bro it's clearly
resource now
if the rumors were true with the whole
microsoft and stuff acquisition
their price was very high and mark
yourself was like
no you know you that you're feeling
yourself a little and we get it
they they they came from a situation
it's like a breakup in a relationship
right yeah and they you know
they the husband they try to get back
together now but now the wife is like
look you know you did me dirty i want
ownership of this and i want all this
you know she she putting out these
outrageous demands
and microsoft is like all right it's
cool we just friends with benefits
like that's where it's at right now so
yeah so until maybe you know get her
expectations down a little
you know what i'm saying or maybe daddy
tencent come through you know what i'm
saying be like yo he throwing cash all
over the place he's
buying up everything and they just made
an announcement that
tencent is looking to buy a large
company just just like yesterday
so everyone's bracing this is this is
we're in the age of cloud and
information and companies acquisition
so bungie could position himself right
at the end of the day destiny is still
that ip
that will do well for you you know what
i'm saying you still got another ip
they're still one of the greatest
shooters going they have caches no doubt
it's just to me they need that buyer
then i think we get the resources
then we get the consistency that we want
as hardcore gamers and i think that
that's just where i'm at with it but
i i'm gonna die on the resource thing
with them it's got to be
yeah i think that probably wraps it
pretty well
but i was like we could we could
speculate but it's like i just can't
wait to read that because i have
honestly no idea where it's gonna go
that's gonna be a hell of a podcast i
don't know who the guest is gonna be for
that one but
somebody's gonna have an interesting
chat with us that's for sure brother i
can't wait ain't nothing better than
those
luke smith two to three page background
there's like
three parts to one of those remember we
got like one
part in the next week we got like part
three
we got it bit as much as we [ __ ] you
can play it is always fun during these
times with destiny like
just to see the transformations of this
game this thing has gone through so many
iterations and and love hate and
but it's those moments right we sit
there and we reena and that's why i said
i always gonna ride with them
because no other developer i've seen is
that transparent with their community
where they're like look this is what
happened or during the year
you get you get like a novel dear diary
i was mad at you when you did this oh
but that's why you did it
okay cool and then it's like it's just
love hate we're never going nowhere we
love this game the gun play is amazing
the raid's the
best end game ever we just wanted to be
at its pristine state
and in the meantime like a wise man told
me he bought just just play other stuff
with your visible man
play other stuff with your message boo
you got other things to do finish these
games
they're going to get it right or someone
somebody gonna buy them and get get
married
[Laughter]
own their ship
that ball and chain down facts lock it
up somebody put a ring on this
please clear
i'm just like they need it but it's like
they've fought so hard to get free and
they've been it's
nice it's just i feel like i see it
being such
a hard path for them to do i'm not
saying it won't happen and i'm not
saying somebody like microsoft
doesn't have enough money but they
fought to be free twice
and i was like they are they are way too
comfortable in the bachelor pad with
beers in the fridge and the livestream
tv set up they don't want that
they don't want that
[Music]
it well that's about probably all we got
today this is definitely a long episode
sorry we took a lot of your time cloud
but it's been
a lot of fun sir um but as we wrap up
um the floor is yours to let everybody
know where to find you
anything cool you got cooking both in
the kitchen and in gaming
where can they yeah cheese real high
over here
like where can they find you what's the
good place to see you stuff to expect
what are you what are you known for what
do you got what do you got coming
okay so as far as anything destiny i
will cover absolutely
anything interesting doesn't matter
whether you're new whether you're
a veteran it doesn't matter there'll
always be something relevant to you on
the channel you find me over on youtube
at cloudplays
uh i post up a load of random stuff on
twitter
that's pretty much about all i do on
there to be honest so you can find me
there at cloud players under school yt
if you're watching this video format you
can see all the links down below anyway
um and uh yeah hopefully we should see
the crimson cast come summer this year
ellie's gonna be returning back so
we bit off more when we could chew
well all of those hours in the job man
it was it was just way too much
but uh yeah we've we've got we've got
rebranding coming we've got some big
stuff coming look out for crimson cars
this summer so
beautiful that's what i want to hear
brother man congratulations like i said
long overdue for you to be here love
what you're doing just hearing your
story
and all the things you're able to do
with max out of families doing
multitasking doing and still putting out
fantastic content
and appreciate that content yeah so
salute to you brother i always like
vibing with you on social media
you always show last word of love so
it's always loved by me and you warlock
all day every day so i'm right you know
how we fashion now you know
my man salute you already know what
about you
anything exciting coming we've had some
awesome guests on your podcast recently
so if you guys have missed
iron lord's podcast in a bit go look
back through a couple of recent ones
they've had some
fantastic guests on there go check out
some episodes good way to fill your ears
if you're
going on walks probably not a whole lot
of commuting but say you got to clean
your house you know it's a good way to
knock it out
appreciate it yeah actually you don't
want to jinx it we may have someone
special but it's not confirmed so
gotta wait until i can't absolutely
officially normally don't
give everybody the last and the last one
i always give people a preview
yeah i mean that's the last word they
know it takes back so if not like i said
we still have a good show regardless but
if it's not this week with a special
guest it'll most likely be next week
but we really appreciate it man it's
been it's been truly cool
everybody i see people that were on the
last world actually show come by show
love to imo podcast
means a lot and obviously lords of
gaming.net the website you know it's
really cool to see the growth there
so much appreciation on the support and
if you're in the statues my brother king
david he does uh king of the statues
he's got this crazy anubis statue right
now it's amazing
please check that out if you're in the
comics and all that stuff and
of course do this last word thing here
i love to do my brother igbonte is
always fun man and
he hates what i said but i just think
we're a very underrated podcast and
more people should listen so that's all
i'll say
i'll be humble with it but uh i love
doing this show it's these type of
conversations are
just organic it's great and um hopefully
like i said more people listen and
and bungie you you too can listen and
also come on the show sometime
check us out
we don't bite hard we don't bite we kind
of
yeah same thing i was like you guys i
don't know me as i said like depending
i'll be playing whatever's new in
destiny seeing what's going on and you
know i'll always come back here and
there but i was like i've also been
enjoyed mixing it up builder b you guys
see me streaming on youtube i did the
full miles morales playthrough in one
stream on youtube so that nine hours was
kind of awesome but very cool so you
guys will find me whether videos on
youtube stream on youtube twitch twitter
you guys know where to find me it's
ibontist basically everywhere doing
something in the world of gaming and
just technology i'm also a big giant
nerd so
computers are fun uh i enjoy my parts
but
all of that being said for this episode
thank you guys very much we are going to
go raid
donnie and other last rites brethren
over here also a guy who's altered to
fitness he actually helps people like
goes out and like lives with people and
like he's doing big time fitness things
so an awesome guy to support so
definitely send some love when i read
you guys over there send him follows and
everything else like that but for this
episode
133 the guest of honor the distinguished
gentleman
sir cloudplays thank you very much for
joining us it was a pleasure it was a
blast
believe me you will you will always be
open invite to come back if you ever
want to so
100 it's been a pleasure yeah um but to
wrap this one up
thank you guys very much episode 133 for
january 22nd
it has been the last word